ओके सो वी आर लाइव नाउ आई थिंक सो ओके लेट
मी सी इफ वी आर
लाइव चलिए
तो
ओके सो हम लाइव है गाइस
एंड या सो एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए सभी को
मेरी आवाज जा रही है क्लियर एकदम से
क्लियर जा रही है मेरी आवाज बता दीजिए एक
बार जल्दी से फटाफट बता दीजिए प्लीज एवरी
बडी एवरी बडी लेट मी नो इफ आई एम ऑडिबल
एंड विजिबल मैं भी देख लेता हूं फोन पर
दूसरे वाले फोन पर मैं देख लेता
हूं लेट मी सी इ आई एम लाइव परफेक्टली
चलिए
तो मुझे चैट में बता दीजिए जल्दी से सभी
ऑडियो
वीडियो ओके
सॉरी ओके सो या आई एम वेरी मच क्लियर
ऑडियो एंड वीडियो सब कुछ सही है चलिए
वेलकम एवरी बडी टू द डे सेवन ऑफ दिस बग
बाउंट फ्री कोर्स और आज का दिन आज का यह
जो क्लास है
वो वन ऑफ द मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट सेशंस ऑफ बग
बाउंट कोर्स का होने वाला है क्योंकि
इंपॉर्टेंट सेशंस बहुत सारे आने वाले हैं
अभी आने वाले क्लासेस में बट आज का उनमें
से बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है आप यह मान
के चलिए क्योंकि आज हम करने वाले हैं सब
डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन ठीक है अब ये सब डोमेन
एन्यूमरेशन क्या चीज है क्यों हम करते हैं
सारी चीजें हम जानेंगे एक-एक करके देखेंगे
एंड इसकी क्या इंपॉर्टेंस है यह भी हम
समझेंगे आज के इस सेशन में ठीक है
चलिए सो लेट एवरीबॉडी जॉइन
हियर ओके गुड इवनिंग
सबको गुड इवनिंग राधे राधे गुड इवनिंग
सबको
भाई सबका स्वागत
है चलिए चलिए तो काफी लोग आ चुके हैं
ऑलरेडी एंड वी आर गोइंग टू स्टार्ट सो आई
एम नितेश फाउंडर ऑफ डेनिक्स एंड लेट्स
बिगिन द डे सेवन ऑफ दिस बग बाउटी फ्री
अ कोर्स
चलिए तो आज के सेशन में हम सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन सब डोमेन हंटिंग इसके बारे में
थोड़ा जानने वाले हैं क्यों जरूरी है पहले
मैं आपको यह बता देता हूं कि क्यों यह
जरूरी है ठीक है व्हाई इट्स वेरी मच
इंपॉर्टेंट टू इनमेट सब डोमेंस अब देखो
मैं आपको बताता हूं जैसे पानी आपके लिए
डेली पीनस जरूरी है खाना आपके लिए डेली
खाना जरूरी है हवा आपके लिए उतनी ही जरूरी
है वैसे ही बग बाउंट में सब डो डोमस फाइंड
करना आपके लिए उतनी ही जरूरी है सब डोमेंस
के बिना आपका बग बाउंट जर्नी अधूरा माना
जाता है एंड आप आगे कुछ प्रोसेस कर ही
नहीं पाएंगे क्योंकि अब देखो दो तरह की
सिनेरियो मैं आपको समझाता हूं बताता हूं
आप उसको समझिए आपको ज्यादा क्लियर हो
जाएगा कि व्हाई वी नीड टू इनमेट सब डोमेन
एंड देन हम सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन करना
स्टार्ट करेंगे प्रैक्टिकली हम बहुत सारे
टूल सेट्स बहुत सारी चीजें हम देखने वाले
हैं अभी तो बहुत सारी चीजें हैं जो अभी
अभी स्टार्ट नहीं हुई है वो सारी चीजें भी
इस क्लास में आपको देखने को मिल जाए बट
इसके पहले मैं आपसे जानना चाहता हूं सबसे
सबसे जानना चाहता हूं भैया एकदम ईमानदारी
से बताइए कि ट्राई हैक मी के जो टास्क
मैंने आपको दिए थे आप सबने किए या नहीं
किए पहला क्वेश्चन यह है मेरा कितने लोगों
ने टास्क किया टास्क आपको क्या मिला था
आपको टास्क मिला था एक तो इंट्रोडक्शन टू
साइबर सिक्योरिटी ये तो कंप्लीट करना ही
है ठीक है उसके बाद यहां पे आपको मिला था
प्री सिक्योरिटी वाला जो पाथ है लर्निंग
पाथ इस पे आपको जाना था प्री सिक्योरिटी
के एंड इसको आपको कंप्लीट करना था साथ में
हाउ द वेब वर्क्स यह वाला भी करना था यह
सारी चीजें मतलब ऑलमोस्ट आपको कंप्लीट कर
लेनी थी यह टास्क था कितने लोगों ने किया
है लेट मी
नो चलिए
बताइए ठीक है किया है काफी लोगों ने किया
है बहुत अच्छी बात है जिन लोगों ने नहीं
किया है आपसे मैं ज्यादा उम्मीद नहीं
करूंगा क्योंकि अगर इतने बोलने के बाद भी
आप नहीं कर इसका मतलब आप सिंसियर नहीं है
बग बाउटी इस फ्री कोर्स के लिए आप बस वैसे
ही हैं तो आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट लास्ट में
करूंगा कि जो लोगों ने अभी तक नहीं किया
और अगर आप रियली है सिंसियर है ना तो आप
उस टास्क को कीजिए जो मैं बताऊं टास्क जो
मैं बोलू जैसे बोलू वैसे कीजिए कम से कम
फॉलो करने में कुछ नहीं जा रहा ना आपका वो
काम तो करो यार प्लीज इतना कर लो यार इतने
करने में क्या जाता है तुम्हारा बताओ क्या
जाता है पैसे लग रहे हैं तुम्हारे घर घर
भी करा है तुम्हारा कुछ नहीं जा रहा भाई
एकदम फ्री का फंडा है भाई कोई दिक्कत नहीं
हां और ट्राई हैक मी के सब्सक्रिप्शन के
बारे में फ्री का मैंने कभी नहीं बोला
आपको कि आपको फ्री में मिल जाएगा ठीक है
कहीं नहीं मिलता है फ्री में आपको खरीदना
ही पड़ेगा इसका जो सब्सक्रिप्शन है वही है
यह कॉस्टली देते हैं बाकी मैं आपको इसका
अल्टरनेटिव मतलब थोड़ा सा चीपर अल्टरनेटिव
बता सकता हूं वो ग्रा प आपको मैंने बताया
था काफी लोगों के मैसेज आए हैं थोड़ा वेट
कीजिए आपको रिस्पांस मिल जाएगा टीम के तरफ
से आपको रेस्पों कर दिया जाएगा एंड देन यू
कैन अंडरस्टैंड द थिंग्स ठीक है चलिए तो
यह आपने कर लिया होगा दूसरी चीज मैंने
काली लिनिक्स की प्लेलिस्ट आप सबको बता आई
थी कंप्लीट करने के लिए आई डोंट नो आप आप
लोगों में से कितने लोगों ने किया है बट
मैंने बताया था आप लोगों को एक और टास्क
जो दिया था वो यह बताया था कि टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर इस
youtube1 पार्ट टू पार्ट पार्ट थ्री पार्ट
फोर पाट पार्ट फाइव पार्ट सिक्स तक मैंने
टास्क दिया था कंप्लीट करने का सो आई होप
कि आपने व किया होगा नहीं किया तो उसको कर
लीजिएगा नेक्स्ट क्लास से भी पहले क्योंकि
इसके बिना आप अधूरे हैं एंड आपकी लिनिक्स
की नॉलेज अगर अधूरी है तो आपको बहुत कुछ
नहीं समझ में आएगा स्पेशली काली लिनिक्स
की मैं बात कर रहा हूं यहां पे ठीक है
दैट्ची को जवाइन करके रखिएगा लिंक
डिस्क्रिप्शन में इसी वीडियो के लाइव के
मिल जाएगा आपको क्योंकि सारे अपडेट सबसे
पहले वहीं आपको मिलेंगे जो भी रिसोर्सेस
है सब आपको वहीं पे मिलेंगे ऐप पे मैंने
आपको फ्री कोर्स वाले में आपको अ
रिसोर्सेस आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं बब
शूट हो गई डॉग्स की लिस्ट हो गई चीट शट हो
गई सारे दे रहा हूं तो उसमें ज्वाइन कर
लीजिएगा रोनिक्स एडमी ए एप पे जाइएगा एंड
वहां पे आप क्या कीजिएगा सिंपली आप उसको
लॉग इन करके फ्री वाली कोर्स में आप जॉइन
करके वो वाली चीजें ले सकते हैं कल
थी आपने देखा होगा वहां कितने सारे टॉप
लेवल डोमेंस जो है वो प्रेजेंट थे आपने
देखा ना कितने टॉप लेवल
टीएलडीपी टॉप लेवल डोमेन सभी इंटरनेट प
काम करते हैं सबको दिखा था
चलिए बढ़िया बढ़िया चलिए बढ़िया है बढ़िया
है अगर आपने देखा था तो बढ़िया
है
ओके अब चलिए अब हम स्टार्ट करते हैं सबसे
पहले समझते हैं सब डोमेन की सब
डोमेन हंटिंग की जरूरत क्यों पड़ती है सब
डोमेन न्यूमरेशन की हमें जरूरत क्यों
पड़ती है अब देखो एक तुम्हारा टारगेट है
मान लो एक टारगेट जैसे मैं क्या करता हूं
बग क्राउड पर ही चल लेते हैं बग क्राउड प
आई होप सो की अकाउंट लॉगइन होगा शायद ओके
लगन नहीं है कोई बात नहीं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है बक क्राउड प चल लेते हैं ठीक है बक
क्राउड प प्रोग्राम में चलते हैं मैं यहां
पे पासवर्ड मांग रहा है पासवर्ड क्या था
पासवर्ड
यार आई डोंट रिमेंबर द पासवर्ड बट स्टिल
लेट्स
ट्राई लेट्स ट्राई ट्राई करता हूं मैं लगन
हो गया क्या अच्छा लगन भी हो गया चलो
बढ़िया तो ब है यहां पे बहुत सारे
प्रोग्राम्स हैं अब देखो यहां पे बहुत
सारे प्रोग्राम्स में से कोई भी एक
प्रोग्राम मैं चूज कर लेता हूं जैसे कि
क्लास डोजो ये वाली मैंने कर लिया मान लो
इसके नीचे आते हैं यहां पे स्कोप एंड
रिवार्ड्स में यहां पे कौन-कौन सी क्या
स्कोप है क्या रिवार्ड्स है इसमें आ जाते
हैं इनके रिवार्ड्स में कुछ ऐसा सब डोमेन
का सिस्टम है नहीं तो इसको स्किप करते हैं
कोई ऐसा बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम खोजते हैं
जहां पे सब डोमेन का कोई कांसेप्ट है जबसे
हब स्पॉट पे चलते हैं लेट्स सी हब स्पॉट
को ओपन कर लेते हैं नीचे आते हैं एंड यहां
पे टारगेट एरिया में आ जाते हैं टारगेट
एरिया में जब आप आप आएंगे तो यहां पर
hubspot.com एक वेबसाइट है इनके इनके
स्कोप में एंड स्टार्टिंग में स्टार डॉट
लगा हुआ है यानी कि hubspot.com के जितने
सब डोमस है सारे इस स्कोप में है अनटिल
अनलेस कोई ऐसा सब डोमेन जो एक्सप्लीसिटली
मेंशन किया गया है कि वो आउट ऑफ स्कोप में
है जो यहां पे मेंशन है आउट ऑफ स्कोप वो
सिर्फ आउट ऑफ स्कोप है बाकी सारे इन द
स्कोप रहेंगे आपके हब स्पॉट के ठीक है
भैया इतना समझ में आ रहा है इतना कि आपके
हॉटस्पॉट के इन
दस इन द स्कोप रहेंगे ठीक है चलिए सभी लोग
सुन पा रहे हैं ना
यार
ओके किसी को पता है कि
नॉर्मली क्या है यूजुअली अगर तुम एक
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर हो बग
बाउंटीज कोई क्या करता है डोमेन डोमेन पे
हंट करता है डोमेन पे बट हम अगर सब डोमेन
पे हंट करें तो हमारे चांसेस ज्यादा होंगे
वहां लेबिलिटी फाइंड करने की उसके बाद हम
अगर सब सब डोमेन पे हंट करें यानी कि
सेकंड लेवल सब डोमेन पे अगर हंट करते हैं
वहां और भी ज्यादा चांसेस होंगे हमारी
वलने बिलिटी फाइंड करने के ये एक जनरिक
चीजें होती है जैसे मान लो तुम एक अटैकर
हो तुम एक एथिकल हैकर हो सिक्योरिटी
रिसर्चर हो वाइटहेड हो तुम्हें एक डोमेन
मिला कौन सा हबस्पॉट
कॉ ये तुम्हारा टारगेट है अब तुमने इसको
तो चलो हंट करना शुरू किया इस पे लेबिलिटी
फाइंड करनी शुरू की बट hubspot.com मेन
डोमेन पे क्या होता है एक्चुअली ऑलरेडी
बहुत सारे जो हैकर्स हैं जो एथिकल हैकर्स
हैं रिसर्चस हैं वो ऑलरेडी उसमें बहुत
सारी एफर्ट अपनी लगा चुके होते हैं टाइम
अपना लगा चुके होते हैं एंड उसपे स्कैन कर
चुके होते हैं उसमें लेबिलिटी फाइंड करने
की कोशिश कर चुके होते हैं वहां पे आपको
डुप्लीकेट्स मिलने के चांसेस ज्यादा हो
जाएंगे एंड ज्यादा वैलिड बग मिलने के
चांसेस आपके कम हो जाएंगे एंड वहां आपको
टाइम भी काफी लगेगा तो अब हम आते हैं
नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे सब डोमेन पे अब इस सब
डोमेन पे भी बहुत लोग पहुंच जाते होंगे
ओबवियस है कि सब डोमेन पे भी बहुत लोग
पहुंच रहे हैं फिर सब सब डोमेन पे सेकंड
लेवल वाले पे इस पे भी बहुत लोग पहुंच
सकते हैं फिर एक और फिर क्या करेंगे सब
सब यह मैं लिखने के लिए बस लिख रहा हूं सब
डोमेन यानी इस सब डोमेन का भी सब डोमेन जो
है वहां तक पहुंचने की कोशिश करेंगे थर्ड
लेवल पे ऐसे करते करते करते करते हम आगे
तक पहुंचने की कोशिश करेंगे एंड जितने डीप
जा सकते हैं जितनी इन इनर हायरर की के सब
डोमेन को हम फाइंड कर सकते हैं ट्राई
करेंगे फाइंड करने का एंड उसपे जो है ना
किसी भी तरह की वल्नरेबल मिलने के चांसेस
बहुत बहुत बहुत ज्यादा बढ़ जाते हैं वेरी
वेरी हाई प्रोबेबिलिटी टू गेट अ वैलिड
लेबिलिटी क्योंकि वहां तक बहुत कम लोग
पहुंचे ये वही एक एग्जांपल के थ्रू बताता
हूं एग्जांपल के थ्रू क्या बताता हूं कि
मान लो तुम्हें एक तुम्हारी एक डेस्टिनेशन
है तुम्हें एक तुम्हारी एक क्या है
डेस्टिनेशन है माउंट एवरेस्ट की जो अ पीक
है वो तुम्हारा मान लो डेस्टिनेशन है
जिसको हम समिट बोलते हैं समिट माउंट
एवरेस्ट का सबसे हाईएस्ट जहां पे लोग जाके
झंडे ड़ते हैं जहां पे जाके लोग अ एक
रिकॉर्ड बनाते हैं अब तुम माउंटेनियर हो
चढ़ाई कर रहे हो तुम्हारे साथ-साथ 10 लोग
और चढ़ रहे हैं अब बीच में कई हर्डल्स
आएंगे बीच में कई तरह के पड़ाव आएंगे ये
सब डोमेन जो है ये सारे पड़ाव हैं इस
डोमेन के अब लास्ट तक तुम जब पहुंच जाओगे
तो तुम्हारी विक्ट्री हो जाती है वैसे ही
जब तुम लास्ट एकदम इनर सब डोमेन पार्ट तक
पहुंच जाओगे तो वहां पे तुम्हें ज्यादा
चांसेस होते हैं एक वैलिड बग फाइंड करने
का उस पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन के ऊपर अब वो बग
किसी भी तरह का हो सकता है किसी भी तरह की
वनबिल हो सकती है अलग-अलग वनबिल ट्राई
करेंगे हम अपने चेकलिस्ट के अकॉर्डिंग
एक-एक करके एक-एक करके खोजें भाई मिलेगा
यार कैसे नहीं मिलेगा जरूर मिलेगा ठीक है
जरूर मिलेगा
चलिए तो हमें हमें इसलिए सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन करनी है एंड हमारा रेकन का पहला
जो यह पार्ट है पहला या दूसरा आप स्टेप
बोल सकते हो पहले स्टेप में हमने क्या
किया था हमने इंटेल गैदर किए थे जितनी
इंटेल हो सकते है जितनी जानकारी हो सकती
है एक डोमेन के बारे में हमने उठाया था
उसके वर्टिकल कोरलेन हॉरिजॉन्टल कोरिले
मेनली हमने बेसिकली क्या किया था
हॉरिजॉन्टल वाले का पता हॉरिजॉन्टल कोरिले
फाइंड किया था कि एक अ लाइक एक कोई डोमेन
है पर्टिकुलर जैसे hubspot.com है हस्प
कंपनी है तो इससे रिलेटेड इसके डोमस कितने
हैं कौन-कौन वो सब निकालो और फिर सब के सब
डोमेंस निकालने की कोशिश करो तो हमारा
ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या होगा सेशन का फाइंड एज
मेनी सब डोमेंस
वी कैन ठीक है दूसरा सारे सब डोमेंस हमने
फाइंड कर लेने हैं उसके बाद जब सारे सब
डोमेंस हमने फाइंड कर लिए तो हमें उसमें
से क्या करना है डुप्लीकेट्स हटाना है
रिमूव द डुप्लीकेट्स एंट्री अब हो सकता है
तुम मल्टीपल तरीके यूज कर रहे हो सब डोमेन
फाइंड करने करने के तो तुम्हें कुछ
डुप्लीकेट्स भी मिल जाए अलग-अलग टूल सेट
से तो उन डुप्लीकेट्स को हटा देंगे
थर्ड शॉर्ट आउट द लाइव सब डोमेंस लाइव जो
सब डोमेंस है उनको शॉर्ट आउट करेंगे या
इसको बोल दो कि वेब
सर्वर वेब सर्वर फिंगरप्रिंट
करेंगे ठीक है चौथा जो है वो स्क्रीनशॉट
ले लेंगे ताकि हमें पता चले उस पर्टिकुलर
सब डोमेन पे क्या-क्या क्या-क्या है अब
मान लो तुम हमारे पास 100 सब डोमेंस की
लिस्ट है मुझे बताओ एक क्वेश्चन है सबसे
देखते हैं कितने लोगों को क्या आंसर अ पता
है मेरे पास 100 सब डोमेन की एक लिस्ट है
एक फाइल है टी एक्सटी फाइल अब मुझे देखना
है कि उन सब डोमस पे सब डोमस भी क्या है
एक वेबसाइट है उन सब डोमस पे 100 के 100
सब डोमस पे क्या-क्या चीजें आ रही है जब
हम उस सब डोमेन को ओपन कर रहे हैं जब हम
उन सब डोमेन को ओपन कर रहे हैं तो क्या
सामने फर्स्ट पेज क्या डिस्प्ले हो रहा है
इंडेक्स पेज क्या डिस्प्ले हो रहा है ये
हमें मुझे फाइंड करना है मुझे पता करना है
तो सबसे इ वे आपको क्या लगता है क्या हो
सकता है मुझे बताइए सभी लोग
बताइए सॉरी सभी लोग बताइए सबसे इजी वे
क्या हो सकता है लेट मी नो व्ट व्ट मे बी
द इजस्ट वे फॉर फाइंडिंग कि क्या आ रहा है
फर्स्ट पेज
पे देखते हैं आपके दिमाग कहां तक जा रहा
है बताते जाइए ठीक
है
चलिए सही है अ गर्वित वर्मा स्क्रीनशॉटिंग
बिल्कुल
हालाकि मैंने फोर्थ स्टेप यहां लिखा हुआ
था बट करेक्ट आंसर है एंड दिस इज नोन एज
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग हम स्क्रीनशॉट करेंगे ना
यार हम स्क्रीनशॉट ले लेंगे एक फोल्डर में
डाल देंगे एक फोल्डर में स्क्रीनशॉट रहेगा
सारे सब डोमस का 100 के 100 का हम बस यहां
एरो की एक पिक्चर को ओपन करेंगे एरो की
प्रेस करते करते हम 100 आराम से देख लेंगे
कोई टेंशन की बात नहीं है कि कौन-कौन से
सब डोमेन पे क्या हमारा सामने जो है वो
क्या शो हो रहा है क्या आ रहा है बस सिंपल
सा फंडा है यार कहां कोई टेंशन है ना बस
सिंपल सी चीज
है ठीक है तो यह काम करेंगे हमारा मेन
ऑब्जेक्टिव अब ये जो दिखने में चार
ऑब्जेक्टिव है ये बस दिखने में ऐसे आ रहे
हैं बट है बहुत ही ज्यादा क्रिटिकल चीज
बहुत ही कुछ इसमें अभी करना है हमें बहुत
कुछ हम देखेंगे ठीक है बहुत चीजें हम अभी
करने वाले हैं एवरीथिंग वी विल सी चलिए तो
स्टार्ट करते हैं हम अभी
से एंड यहां पे हम हमारा जो टारगेट है हम
उस ट को भी लेके चल सकते हैं
बक क्राउड प क्राउड स्ट्रीम पर चलते हैं
देखते रिसेंट में कौन सी प्रोग्राम में
ज्यादा वटी व लोग आजकल फाइंड कर रहे हैं
सो एक्सफिनिटी
[संगीत]
टेस्ला वेबड कॉ वेबड कॉ ठीक है ब क्राउड
ओके टी मोबाइल टी मोबाइल चलिए अच्छी बात
है यहां पर चलिए टेस्ला भी अच्छा
प्रोग्राम है मेरे ख्याल से सो वी कैन
आल्सो गो फॉर टेस्ला बिकॉज टेला के भी
काफी
लाइक है इन स्कोप में
जो डोमस है तो यहां आप देख सकते हैं टेला
कॉ है टोटल tesla.svs
सडन फिल्टर्स के बारे में एफएफ यूएफ का
इंट्रो सडन सीआई सडन एआई हरड हा और
सीक्रेट्स कुछ फाइंड किए थे वेब आर्काइव
का सीडीए एपीआई यूज़ किया था ठीक है आज के
सेशन में हम सबसे पहले स्टार्ट करते हैं
सीआरटी एसए से अब यह सीआरटी एसए क्या है
चलिए इस पे पहले चलते हैं फिर हम देखते
हैं कि व्हाट दिस सीआरटीएस इज यहां
सीधा-सीधा क्लियर लिखा हुआ है एंटर एन
आइडेंटिटी डोमेन नेम या ऑर्गेनाइजेशन नेम
ईटीसी और सर्टिफिकेट फिंगरप्रिंट और अ
सीआरटी एसए आईडी बेसिकली यह सीआरटी एसए
क्या है सर्टिफिकेट
जो इशू होती हैं एसएसएल सर्टिफिकेट्स जो
डोमस को इशू की जाती हैं हम एक पर्टिकुलर
डोमेन के लिए एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के लिए
जितने भी सर्टिफिकेट्स इश्यूड हैं सिमिलर
जो सेम सर्टिफिकेट्स इश्यूज अथॉरिटी है
जिन्होंने उस डोमेन को इशू किया
सर्टिफिकेट्स उससे रिलेटेड जितने भी
डोमेंस सब डोमेंस या जो भी है एंटिटीज
उनको हम फाइंड करते हैं सीआरटीएस के थ्रू
अब ये एक मैनुअल तरीका है बट बहुत सारे जो
सब डोमेन फाइंडर टूल्स हैं ऑलरेडी
उन्होंने इसको को ऑटोमेट करके अपने में
इंक्लूड करके रखा है तो हम उसको यूज़
करेंगे तो ऑटोमेटिक ये भी यूज़ हो रहा
होगा बैकग्राउंड में बट यहां पे आपको मैं
बैकग्राउंड की टेक्निकल बता रहा हूं ताकि
आपको समझ में आए कि किसी टूल के अंदर अगर
बैकग्राउंड में कुछ चल रहा है तो वो क्या
होता है तो बैकग्राउंड में इस तरह की
सर्विसेस यूज़ होती हैं सीटीएसए वायरस
टोटल नेट क्राफ्ट डीएनए ऐसे-ऐसे जो तरीके
हैं वो यूज़ होते हैं जिससे कि आपको सब
डोमेंस मिल जाते हैं चलिए अब यहां पे आता
है सड एए अब इसको कैसे इसको कैसे यूज़
करना है कैसे फाइंड करेंगे भैया हम
का निकालना है तो इसका एक कीवर्ड एक
कीवर्ड आपको टाइप करना पड़ता है सिंपल
परसेंटेज
facebook.com इस तरह से कुछ आपको राइट
डाउन करना पड़ता है पर facebook.com एंड
यहां पे आपको सर्च पे क्लिक करना है जैसे
ही हम सर्च पे क्लिक करेंगे वीी विल फाइंड
सम रिजल्ट्स हियर जब आप रिजल्ट फाइंड
करेंगे तो यहां लिखा रहेगा प्लीज
रिट्राईंग कुछ सर्टिफिकेट्स जो एक्सपायर्ड
है वो एक्सक्लूड किए गए हैं यहां से उनको
आप इस पे क्लिक करके यहां पे इसके
रिजल्ट्स देख सकते हैं कौन-कौन से
सर्टिफिकेट्स हैं जो एक्सपायर किए गए हैं
एंड वो भी कई बार आपके काम आ सकते हैं तो
यहां पे हमने ये देखिए ये रिजल्ट्स इधर आ
गए आपके बहुत रिजल्ट्स आएंगे एक रिजल्ट
आपके सामने यहां से इस तरीके से कुछ आ गया
अब देखो ये मैनुअल फाइंडिंग कितनी
इंटरेस्टिंग है ना मैं आपको समझा देता हूं
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग होती है ऑटोमेटेड तो ठीक
है आप कर लोगे बट ये मैनुअल तरीका आप जब
मैनुअली कुछ चीजें निकालो ग ना तो उसकी एक
अलग आपको फीलिंग आएगी उसकी एक अलग फील
होगी बहुत शानदार आपको फील आपको देखा
जाएगा चलिए देखते हैं अब यहां पे कुछ
मैनुअल पहले मैं आपको ट्राई बताता हूं फिर
हम ऑटोमेटेड हम टूल्स भी यूज कर लेंगे कोई
टेंशन नहीं है उसके बाद मैं आपको एक
रिपोजिटरी भी बताऊंगा भैया जहां पे सारे
सब डोमस आपको मिलेंगे ऐसे मिलियंस में
बिलियंस में ऐसे करके मिलेंगे बहुत
बड़ी-बड़ी फाइल्स आपको मिलेंगी बहुत सारी
चीजें हैं देखते जाओ बस देखते जाओ मजा है
ठीक है ये इनका सिंटेक्स है सिंटेक्स है
थारा ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पे कुछ सब डोमस
हम निकालते हैं कुछ सब डोमेंस की लिस्ट
यहां पे हम फाइंड करते हैं एंड एक लिस्ट
क्रिएट करने की कोशिश करते हैं है चलिए तो
यहां
पे न्यू टैब ओपन करता हूं मैं यहां पे एंड
मैं थोड़ा इसको स्मॉल छोटा कर देता हूं
एंड लेट्स फाइंड आउट तो कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
जैसे कि मेरे पास कुछ सब डोमेंस निकालते
हैं जैसे एक है यहां पे अ pf.com
secure.in facebook.com चलिए
interface.com तो ये इंटर्न ये कीवर्ड आ
गया आप कीवर्ड्स भी निकाल सकते हैं इस
तरीके से एंड इसको आप फजिंग के लिए यूज़
कर सकते हैं बट ठीक है फिलहाल के लिए
मैंने क्या किया
के लिए यहां पे एक निकाला . facebook.com
यह हमने निकाला ठीक है अब और भी सब डोमस
निकालेंगे यहां पे इंटर्न के बाद हमें कौन
सा
मिला लेटेस्ट facebook.com चलिए लेटेस्ट ड
facebook.com यह एक सब डोमेन हमने यहां पे
फाइंड किया है नाउ वी विल फाइंड अल्फा
अल्फा यह रहा एक अल्फा भी मिला है यहां पे
वाइल्ड कार्ड के साथ है तो यहां बनता है
इसका अल्फा ड फ
बुक कॉ उसके बाद यहां पे चलिए चलते हैं
एंड देन अगेन वी आर गोइंग टू सी m अल्फा
ये इसके सब सब सब सब डोमेन है जैसे देखो
अल्फा मिला हमें अब अल्फा का एक और सब
डोमेन मिला है m.p. facebook.com तो हमें
इसको भी ले लेना है
m.p. facebook.com हम इसको भी ले लेते हैं
इसके अलावा हमें एक और मिला है क्या मिला
भैया fb.me alpha2 देख रहे हो किस लेवल की
आपको सब डोमेन से य पे मिल रहे हैं चलिए
यह भी हमें मिल गया बहुत अच्छी बात है
इसके अलावा . facebook.com दिस इज अ वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग सब डोमेन डेव डेव आपको जहां
मिले स्टग आपको जहां मिले अ जहां पे आपको
वीआईपी मिले जहां पे इस तरह के कुछ आपको
सब डोमस मिलते हैं तो उनको पकड़ लिया करो
जैसे ये देखो
लेवल इसको भी हम यहां पे चिपका देते हैं
प्रेस्टो वाले को भी यहां पे हमने ले
लिया डेव हमें मिला था ऑलरेडी अ वी अ
इंक्लूडेड द डेव देन लेट्स गो प्र
facebook.com दिस इज अ इज आल्सो एन
इंटरेस्टिंग सब डोमेन प्र facebook.com
यहां से उठा लेते हैं इंटर्न का हमने
निकाला था अब देखिए यहां पे हमें m.n.
facebook.com मिला चलिए m.n. facebook.com
ए वाले के लाइन में यहां पे मेंशन कर देते
हैं बढ़िया अ ओके यहां पे आ रहा है ट
mc.com इसके अंदर फिर सिक्योर वाला फंडा
भी है तो चलिए इसको भी उठा लेते हैं
इंटर सॉरी
सॉरी चलिए यहां से उठा लेते हैं इंटर वाला
तो यहां पे ंटर
mc.com यह हमने उठा लिया बहुत बढ़िया अब
इसका भी एक सब डोमेन है हमने इसको भी उठा
लेते हैं हम इसको भी कौन सा है एम m डॉट
है और सिक्योर डॉट है दोनों है तो सिक्योर
और m दोनों को उठा लेते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है सिक्योर भी हमने लगा दिया एंड
यहां पे ड द एंड यहां पे हमने m भी लगा
दिया सो हमने यहां ए भी लगा दिया चलिए तो
हमें एक सब डोमेन यहां भी मिल
गई उसके बाद यहां पे और बहुत सारे सब डोमस
हैं जो आपको यहां पे नीचे आएंगे तो आपको
मिल जाएगा जैसे
fb.com ये हमें मिला था ऑलरेडी हमें पता
था प्रेस्टो हमने निकाल ही लिया था
sg.com ये सारे सब डोमेंस हैं अब चलो इससे
तुम्हें सब डोमेंस की एक आईडिया मिल जाएगी
कि इतने सब डोमस तुम मैनुअली कलेक्ट कर
सकते हो ये मैनुअली अब मैनुअली जब कलेक्ट
कर लो तो interface.com का एक अलग सब
डोमेन फाइंड करो समझ में आ रहा है ये
चीजें यह समझ में आ रहा है . facebook.com
इसका अलग सब डोमेन निकालो उसमें तुम्हें m
इंटर्न मिलेगा और भी मिल सकते हैं फिर
alpha2 इसका एक अलग निकालो फिर .
facebook.com इसका अलग निकालो फिर सब की
पूरी फाइनल लिस्ट बनाओ समझ में आ रहा है
मैं क्या कहने का सेंस है मेरा इस तरीके
से आपको करना है आपके पास एक बहुत बड़ा
स्कोप होगा बहुत ह्यूज सब डोमस की लिस्ट
होगी है जब ह्यूज सब डोमस की लिस्ट होगी
भैया तुम बहुत वैलिड बक फाइंड निकाल सकते
हो बहुत बड़ी बहुत बहुत बहुत बड़ी बात है
ये जितनी बड़ी सब डोमेन लिस्ट उतना ज्यादा
चांस उतनी बड़ी स्कोप उतनी ज्यादा चांस
वैलिड बग फाइंड करने के या वैलिड कुछ
अच्छे खासे लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स भी आपको
मिल जाने के इंफॉर्मेशन डिस्क्लोजर बग
मिलने के डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग करके
वहां से आप बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल
सकते हो एंड बहुत सारी चीजें मिलेंगी भाई
अभी तो देखते जाओ उसके बाद कुछ एक्सपायर्ड
यहां पे आपके सर्टिफिकेट्स जो हैं इसकी
लिस्ट यहां पे दी हुई है आप यहां से भी
निकाल सकते हो जैसे hr.com दिस वन यू गट
ऐसे करके यू कैन फाइंड आउट वैसे ही अब हम
tesla's गो फॉर द
tesla.svs
tesla.svs नरेशन सब डोमेन हंटिंग की जो
हमारी सेशन है बग बाउंट फ्री कोर्स की
इसमें यह थोड़ा लंबा चलेगा लंबा का मतलब
कि एक दिन का लंबा नहीं मत लंबा का मतलब
यह है कि इट विल बी इन टू और थ्री पार्ट्स
यानी कि आज भी चला नेक्स्ट सेशन में भी
शायद यही चलेगा इसके और भी आगे के सॉरी
इसके और भी आगे की चीजें चलेंगी तो आपको
ध्यान देना है क्योंकि ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज है अगर इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं होता इतना मैं
बोलता भी नहीं बट इतना इंपॉर्टेंट है कि
इसके बिना आप आगे बढ़ो ग नहीं याद याद
रखना प्लीज तो ऑलवेज ठीक
है ओके ओके सर्टिफिकेट एक्सपायर्ड हो उसपे
हंट क्यों करना देखो सर्टिफिकेट एक्सपायर
का मतलब है आपका मान लो एसएसएल सर्टिफिकेट
एक्सपायर हो गया उस पर्टिकुलर डोमेन का
मान लो लेट्स सपोज हो सकता है उस वो डोमेन
उसका जो सी नेम है वो पॉइंट कर रहा हो एक
एक ऐसे पेज पे जो कि अन क्लेमड हो जैसे
गिट हब का पेज हो गया या व्हाट एवर
वर्डप्रेस की पेज हो कुछ भी एक साइट उसमें
आप सबट टेकओवर फाइंड कर लो एंड इफ यू विल
रिपोर्ट दैट टू
है वो एक्सपायर हो गया सर्टिफिकेट उससे
उनको मतलब नहीं है उनके स्कोप में है यू
कैन रिपोर्ट इट तो ऑलवेज फाइंड करना है
कोई सा भी एक्सपायर्ड हो नॉन एक्सपायर्ड
हो अगर वहां पे आपको लेबिलिटी मिलती है
[संगीत]
facebooksignup.in साट स्क्रिप्टिंग किसी
प्रोग्राम को एक रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेसेस मान
लो है वो सेल्फ नहीं रिफ्लेक्टेड है मान
लो एंड उसका आपको उन्होंने $100 दे दिया
मान लो $100 दे दिया अब उसी सेल्फ
एक्सेसेस सॉरी उसी एक्सेसेस को अगर आपने
थोड़ा चेन कर दिया एंड आपको आपने उसको
अकाउंट टेकओवर में कन्वर्ट कर दिया मान लो
मान लो अकाउंट टेकओवर में कन्वर्ट कर दिया
देन वो आपका एक हाई प्रायोरिटी का वलने
बिलिटी हो जाता है हाई सीवियरिंग का वलने
बिलिटी हो जाता है एंड यू विल गेट मोर
बाउंटीज फॉर द सेम थिंग ठीक है बस चेनिंग
करने का वो सब हम सीखेंगे सब जानेंगे
टेंशन नहीं लेना हैगा ठीक है तो ये हमें
मिल गई तो ये तो हो गई भैया सीआरटी एसए की
बात जहां पे हमने सीआरटी एसएस से सब
डोमेंस को यहां पे फाइंड किया अब इस तरह
से और भी ऐसे जगह हैं जहां से आप सब
डोमेंस फाइंड करते हो जैसे वायरस
टोटल चलिए वायरस टोटल पे चलते हैं लेट्स
सो अ लेट्स गो टू वायरस टोटल ठीक है वायरस
टोटल पे हम आ गए यहां वायरस टोटल पे आ
जाते हैं ठीक है अब यहां पे
यहां पे आप चलते हैं एंड यहां पे हम एक
कोई सा भी डोमेन सर्च करते हैं कोई सा भी
डोमेन सर्च करते हैं जैसे कि मैं
tesla.svs
[संगीत]
वाइड ठीक है उसके बाद आप आप आएंगे रिलेशंस
पे तो रिलेशंस पे जब आप आएंगे तो यहां पे
आपको सब डोमेंस की एक लिस्ट मिल जाती है
अब ये सारे सब डोमेंस आपको यहां पे शो कर
रहा है देखिए ये सारे सब डोमस 577 सब डोमस
जो है यहां पे आपको ये शो कर रहा है आप इस
पे क्लिक कीजिए ये और भी जो भी इसके अ
लिस्ट है वो सारे लिस्ट आपके सामने आ
जाएंगी ये 577 सब डोमेंस दे आर गिविंग यू
तो आप यहां से भी इस तरीके से भी सब
डोमेंस फाइंड की जा सकती है वायरस टोटल से
एक और टूल टूल या तरीका है नेट क्राफ्ट
डीएनएस ओके नेट क्राफ्ट डीएनएस पर जाएंगे
आप यहां
पे
ओके सॉरी एंड यहां पे साइट कंटेंस ऐसी
साइट्स जो कंटें करती हो क्या
tesla.svs सब डोमेंस यहां पे आप नेक्स्ट
पेज करेंगे आपको फिर से इसका जो नेक्स्ट
पेज है सब डोमस का वो मिल जाएगा तो आप
यहां से भी सब डोमेंस जो है वो निकाल सकते
हैं ये तो कुछ यूजुअल अ लाइक विजुअल तरीके
हो गए विजुलाइज्ड वे हो गए सब डोमस को
फाइंड करने के वेबसाइट पे गए और वहां पे
सब डोमेंस को फाइंड किया अब इसी तरह का एक
रिपोजिटरी है जहां पे सारे आपको अपडेटेड
सब डोमस मिलते हैं ये बहुत ही भयानक
रिपोजिटरी है
मतलब मतलब मैं बताऊं कि नहीं बताऊं बताओ
बहुत शानदार जगह है वहां सारे सब डोमस
मिलते हैं भाई सारे तुम्हारे प्रोग्राम्स
के जनरली नए पुराने जो बिछड़ गए हैं जो
साथ में है सबके मिलेंगे खतरनाक है भाई
बताओ बताओ बताओ बताओ जानना है तो
बोलो जी हां गल डॉक्स का भी यूज कर सकते
हैं जानना है तो बताओ खतरनाक जगह की तो
जगह के बारे में बताऊंगा
मैं जाना है
वो खतरनाक एक रिपोजिटरी है बहुत शानदार
रिपोजिटरी है मैं आपको बता देता
हूं एंड ठीक है मैं आपको बता देता हूं एक
रिपोजिटरी है दिस रिपोजिटरी
इज इज केस रिपोजिटरी बाय प्रोजेक्ट
डिस्कवरी सी एच ए ओ एस केस रिपोजिटरी बाय
प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी आप जब इस पे जाएंगे
केस प्रव
आओ प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी इज नोन फॉर अ दे आर
फ्री एंड ओपन सोर्स टूल्स स्पेशली फॉर बग
बाउंट कम्युनिटी एंड दे डू वेरी ग्रेट
थिंग्स तो काफी सारे इनके टूल्स हैं जो
यूज़ किए जाते हैं न्यूक्लि भी उन्हीं का
इन्हीं का टूल है केस भी उन्हीं का टूल है
अ एक और टूल आता है मतलब बहुत सारे टूल्स
हैं जो प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी के तरफ से मिले
हैं
आपको इस लिस्ट में आप इस वेबसाइट प जब
आएंगे
k.p. पे तो आपको यहां पे टोटल रिकॉर्ड
3.75 1 बिलियन का मिलेगा न्यू रिकॉर्ड्स
लास्ट वीक 4 मिलियन के आसपास का लास्ट आर
3801 रिकॉर्ड्स हमेशा अपडेट होते रहते हैं
आप इनकी ईपीआई की से इनकी सर्विस को भी आप
सीएआई के थ्रू फैच भी कर सकते हैं बट यहां
पे मैं आपको लिस्ट दिखाता हूं नीचे आ जाओ
यहां पे ये देखो क्या दिया हुआ है रिकॉन
डाटा फॉर पब्लिक बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स
जितने पब्लिक बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स हैं
उनके रेकन डाटा यहां पे दिए गए हैं अब
देखो दिस लिस्ट कंटेंस रकॉन डेटा
क्यूरेटेड फ्रॉम आवर डीएनएस डेटा सेट्स
प्लीज सेंड अस ए पुल रिक्वेस्ट टू
एक्सपेंड बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स लिस्टेड
हियर ठीक है आप नीचे यहां पे बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम्स यहां पे लिस्टेड हैं उन सारे
बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स को बेसिकली ये
इंक्लूड करते हैं ठीक है अब यहां पे आ
जाते
हैं यू कैन आल्सो क्वेरी एनी डोमेन यूजिंग
कस ए अ अ कास अ आप जो यह केस एपीआई की है
ना तो केस एपीआई की से आप जितने भी क्वेरी
है वो कर सकते हैं तो ये आप ये जो है ना
k.p. i ये बहुत शानदार रिपोजिटरी है अब
नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां पे अब जैसे मुझे ना
फाइंड करना है सब डोमेन मान लो तो मैं
यहां पे सॉरी ऑल पे कर देता हूं यहां पे
यहां पे न्यू सब डोमेंस में आप ये लिस्ट
ये कर सकते हैं आप बेसिकली फिल्टर तो मैं
यहां सर्च कर देता हूं टेस्ला तो यहां पे
टेस्ला आपको मिल गई अब देखो यहां पे ऑफर्स
रिवॉर्ड यस ऑफर स्वैग नो नंबर ऑफ सब डोमस
10594 इतने सब डोमस ये बता रहा है हमारे
पास इनके इनके लाइक इनके रिपोजिटरी में
यहां पे लिस्टेड है ठीक है अब यहां पे
सबसे बड़ी बात है ना ज्यादा आपको टेंशन
नहीं लेनी है आप यहां पे ये क्लाउड वाले
पे क्लिक करोगे डाउनलोड कर सकते हो तुम
लिटरली भाई पूरी सब डोमेन तुम्हें कोई
एपीआई पीआई की जरूरत वैसे नहीं है सब
डोमेन की लिस्ट डाउनलोड कर लो आगे यूज करो
यार सिंपल अब देखो ये डाउनलोड पे क्लिक
किया वेट करो हो गई डाउनलोड भाई हो गई अब
इस पे चलते हैं एक्सट्रैक्ट कर लेते
हैं टेस्ला और सबसे बड़ी बात पता है क्या
है यह सिर्फ टेस्ला का नहीं करेगा इसके
जितने भी एक्यूजेशंस जो हैं जनरल जो
पब्लिक एक्यूजेशंस हैं और जो भी इनके
लिस्टेड जो स्कोप में डोमेन है के भी
निकाल के दे देता है सबसे बड़ी बात यह है
देखो जैसे कि यह सर सिटी इसके भी सब डोमस
tesla.svs
समझ में आ गया यह पूरा का पूरा आपको
टेस्ला का भाई सब डोमेन प्रोवाइड कर देता
है और यह तो छोड़ो भाई यह देखो जैसे सबसे
बड़ी फाइल यह है
tesla.svs
इनकी भी सब डोमस इंक्लूडेड है
tesla.svs मिला हमें जितने भी इसके स्कोप
में है वह सारे आपको यह प्रोवाइड कर देता
है बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट कोई पैसा नहीं
लेगा यह बहुत अच्छी बात है इनकी प्रोजेक्ट
कास की चलिए तो कास प्रोजेक्ट प आपको यह
सारी चीजें मिल जाएंगी इसको आप भले
बुकमार्क कर लीजिए दिमाग में डाल लीजिए इस
वेबसाइट को केस डट कास बोल लो केस बोलो
केस बोलते हैं इसको ठीक है ना प्रोनंसिएशन
प ज्यादा ध्यान नहीं देना है सीखना है
k.d. इस पर आ जाइए बात खत्म अब मुझे
ये देखो
भाई बेचारे बहुत पहले से हैं इसलिए उसके
बाद यहां
google2 6000 समझ में आ रहा है ना मोस्टली
डेड होंगे नहीं ऐसा कुछ नहीं है मोस्टली
डेड होंगे ऐसा कोई कुछ नहीं है आप फाइंड
करोगे ना यार तो आप फाइंड करोगे ना कि डेड
है कि नहीं है वो आपके हाथ में है डेड
वाले को हटा दो एकदम लाइव वाले को रखो भाई
ये तो आपके हाथ में है तो ये एटलीस्ट दे
तो रहे हैं भाई दिस इज द अपडेटेड ये देखो
ना यार लास्ट अपडेट 13 आर अगो ये ऐड करते
रहते हैं अपडेट करते र रहते हैं सबसे बड़ी
बात यही है तो
केपरी मस्त लगा ना ये कैसा लगा ये वेबसाइट
आपको कितना कितना शानदार वेबसाइट है ना
मजेदार है ना यह है एक वेबसाइट बढ़िया
वाली 764 बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम्स की इसमें
लिस्टेड है ठीक है भैया लव फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रदर
ओके ओके ओके कोई अगर आप कोई डिस्टर्ब कर
रहा है अगर चैट में तो मुझे बता दीजिए मैं
उनको 24 आवर्स के लिए टाइम आउट कर दूंगा
ताकि बाकी लोगों का कंसंट्रेशन हो स्पेशली
जो भी यहां पे कर रहे हैं ठीक
है ओके
प्लीज स्क्रीन ब्लर दिख रही है आप अपने
youtube0 में जाइए ऊपर में टैप कीजिएगा
सेटिंग आइकन पे वहां पे जो क्वालिटी है
उसको एचडी कर
दीजिए ठीक है एचडी कर लीजिए उसको क्वालिटी
को बढ़ा दीजिए आपका स्क्रीन सही हो जाएगा
तानिया भारद्वाज ठीक है चलिए तो यह तो
आपको समझ में आ गया भैया चलिए ये आपको
लिस्ट निकल जाएगी बट यार यहां हमें ना
हमें भैया यहां पे ये ऑटोमेशन वाले मतलब
ये बनी बनाई चीज मिल जाए ये इसमें मजा
नहीं है हम तो फाइंड करेंगे हम तो क्या
करेंगे फाइंड करेंगे खुद से हम तो खुद से
बैंड बजाएंगे सब डोमस फाइंड करने की कोशिश
करेंगे एंड इसी के लिए हम यूज करने वाले
हैं सेट ऑफ कुछ टूल्स को जो कि काफी
ज्यादा पॉपुलर है इनके अलावा और भी बहुत
सारे टूल्स हैं सब डोमेन फाइंड करने के 00
टूल्स है सब डोमेन फाइंड करने के बट जो
मैं टूल आपको बताने जा रहा हूं वो वही
टूल्स है जो जनरली मैं भी यूज़ करता हूं
एंड काफी सारे हंटर्स यूज़ करते हैं ऑन
डेली बेसिस पे आप भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं दीज
आर वेल टेस्टेड एंड वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग
टूल्स इसके लिए हमें काली
डे फोनिक्स अकेडमी पे जो इंस्टॉलेशन
वीडियो थी जिनको नहीं पता था वो देख सकते
थे एंड देन दे कुड दे कैन यूज द काली तो
काली लेक्स में चलना है आपको टर्मिनल को
ओपन करना है सबसे पहले गाइस सबसे पहले हम
एक सबसे शानदार टूल यूज करेंगे सबसे मोस्ट
इजी टू यूज टूल आप बोल सकते हो ये दोदो
कौन सी खुली है भाई इसको एक बंद कर दो हां
मोस्ट इजी टू यूज टूल यूज करेंगे फॉर
फाइंडिंग द सब डोमेंस एंड दैट इज नोन एज
सब फाइंडर ठीक है सब फाइंडर तो चलिए यहां
पे मैं क्रम firefox.exe
रिटर्न्स वैलिड सब डोमस फॉर वेबसाइट्स
यूजिंग पैसिव ऑनलाइन सोर्सेस अब भैया
सोर्सेस कौन से ये यूज करता है बहुत सारे
सोर्सेस यूज करता है कौन-कौन से ये
देखिए
देखिए यहां पे ये कुछ अ ऐसे सोर्सेस है जो
एपीआई इन में चाहिए होता है बाकी और बहुत
सारे सोर्सेस हैं जो यह यूज करता है तो
इसको यूज इसको इंस्टॉल कैसे करना है इसको
कंफिल कैसे करना है अगर आप काली यूज करते
हैं तो काली के रिपोजिटरी में ऑलरेडी सब
फाइंडर इंक्लूडेड है दैट्ची काली इज अ गुड
टू गो ए मस्ट हैव ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फॉर बग
बाउंट स्पेशली क्योंकि उसके अंदर आपको
टूल्स इतने मिल जाते हैं ना काली हो गया
पैरेट हो गया कि आपको अलग से ना ज्यादा
कुछ नहीं करना पड़ता बस इंस्टॉल करो यूज
करना शुरू करो क्योंकि उसमें हमें ज्यादा
टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करना है कि कॉन्फिन करें
ये करें वो करें अब उसमें एरर आई तो उसको
सॉल्व करो ना भाई बग्स फाइंड करने हैं
हमें ये नहीं करना कि टूल को हम चला कैसे
रहे हैं बक्स फाइंड करने हैं भाई कैसे
जितना फास्ट फाइंड करोगे उतना ज्यादा आगे
रहोगे जितनी अच्छी मैथोलॉजी होगी उतनी
ज्यादा वैलिड बक्स मिलने के चांसेस रहेंगे
अदर वाइज डुप्लीकेट्स ही मिलेंगे मोस्ट ऑफ
द टाइम ये बात याद रखिएगा चलिए तो भैया अब
यहां पे आ गए हम अ सब फाइंडर पे इसको अब
यूज करना है तो काली के अंदर मैंने आपको
पहले ही बताया क्या है
एप्ट लिस्ट सब फाइंडर ये करना है एंटर
करना है एंड यू विल सी कि सब फाइंडर
ऑलरेडी है और इंस्टॉल्ड भी है इंस्टॉल अगर
आपका नहीं हो तो पट इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा सब
फाइंडर कर लीजिएगा
दैट्ची ऑलरेडी टोल्ड यू गाइ कि सब फाइंडर
हान एच लिखना है कोई भी टूल हो नहीं आता
है यूज करने हान ए या हान हान हेल्प लिख
दीजिए एंड आप उसकी हेल्प फाइल देख के समझ
सकते हैं कैसे यूज़ करना है किसी बहुत
सारे टूल्स का ना कमांड्स का मैनुअल पेज
होता है तो आप मैन स्पेस अन उस टूल का नाम
लिख दीजिए तो आपको मैनुअल भी आपका उसका
मिल जाएगा बहुत सारे टूल्स का आपको नहीं
भी मिलेगा बहुत सारे का मिल जाएगा मैनुअल
तो आपको मैनुअल में भी आप देख सकते हैं
फिलहाल हम इसका हान h का कमांड यूज करने
वाले
हैं कहां गया सब
फाइंडर हाइन एच सॉरी हाइन एच एंड इट विल
गिव यू द हेल्प फाइल अब मुझे फाइंड करने
हैं डोमेंस सबसे पहले मैं टेस्ला का ही
फाइंड करने की कोशिश करता हूं वी विल
ट्राई टू फाइंड टेस्ला बट उसके पहले क्या
जरूरी है पहले आप इस बात को ना थोड़ा
समझिए क्या हमें करना है इस चीज को समझिए
देखिए सब फाइंडर पे आप जब नॉर्मली हंटिंग
करेंगे ना सब डोमेन फाइंड करेंगे तो आपको
लिमिटेड सब डोमेंस मिलने वाले हैं बट जब
आप टूल के अंदर किसी टूल के अंदर जहां
एपीआई कॉन्फिन की फीचर दिए हैं अगर आपने
उसमें एपीआई की डाल दिया तो वो सारे
रिसोर्सेस सोर्सेस से फेच करेगा सब डोमेन
जो ये सपोर्ट करता है एपीआई नहीं डालेंगे
तो बिना एपीआई वाले जो सोर्सेस हैं उनसे
ये सब डोमेन फाइंड करके नहीं देने वाला है
आपको सीधी सधी बात है ठीक है अब जैसे कि
मैं क्या करता हूं इसके सोर्सेस देखता हूं
सब फाइंडर हाइन एलएस अब जब तुम सब फाइंडर
हाइ फन एलएस करोगे तो यहां ये जितने
सोर्सेस यूज करते हैं ना भैया वो सारे
सोर्सेस यहां पे आपको यहां पे दिख जाएंगे
सारे दिख
जाएंगे दिख गया अब यहां दिख रहा है सब
फाइंडर वर्जन आउटडेटेड है अपडेटेड नहीं है
भैया तो कोई बात नहीं हम अपडेट कर लेंगे
एप्ट अपडेट कर लेते हैं पैकेजेस को अपडेट
कर लेंगे अपग्रेड कर लेंगे व्हाट एवर वी
कैन तो हम जो भी अपडेट अपग्रेड वाला काम
करते हैं वो कर लेते हैं ठीक है तो हम
यहां पे पहले तो एप्ट अपडेट चला देंगे फिर
एप्ट अपग्रेड करा देंगे न्यू टैब में एप्ट
अपग्रेड चला देते हैं व्हाट एवर जो भी
अपडे अपडेट वगैरह अपग्रेड वगैरह होना होगा
यह अपना होता रहेगा चलिए सो
लेट्स ओके काफी सारे यहां पे है एंड लेट्स
सी ओके चलिए अपग्रेड कर लेते हैं देखते
हैं तो यहां पे यह तो हो गया यहां
पे 100 सिक्स पैकेजेस ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है हां तो इसके
सोर्सेस हम पहले देख रहे थे अब यह सोर्सेस
की जो लिस्ट है अब इन सोर्सेस के लिस्ट
में जिसमें स्टार लगा है ऐसे देखो यह देखो
यह सब स्टार वाले सोर्सेस है यहां पे सर्च
स्पॉटर स्टार लगा है यहां पे लीक स्टार
लगा यहां पे पैसिव टोटल स्टार लगाया
शोडाउन स्टार लगाया वायरस टोटल स्टार लगा
है जूम आई स्टार लगा है इसका मतलब इन सब
सोर्सेस से रिजल्ट्स अगर आपको चाहिए तो
आपको एपीआई की इनकी कन्फर करनी पड़ेगी अदर
वाइज ये सोर्सेस यूज नहीं होंगे सब डोमेंस
को फाइंड करके देने के लिए यानी कि जो
रिसर्चर बिना एपीआई की वाला यूज कर रहा है
बिना एपीआई की डाले यूज कर रहा है
ओबवियसली उसके रिजल्ट्स कम आएंगे जो एपीआई
की डाल के इनमेट कर रहा है सब डोमस के
उसके ज्यादा आने आएंगे जो रिजल्ट्स हैं
एंड उसके ज्यादा वैलिड स्कोप एक बनेगा
वैलिड बाउंटीज बग मिलने के चांसेस बढ़
जाएंगे बाउंटीज बढ़ने मिलने के चांसेस
आपके बढ़ जाए जाते हैं तो एपीआई की कन्फर
करना बहुत जरूरी है भाई अब ये देखो देखो
ये तो हो गया अब इसकी एपीआई की कन्फर कहां
से करेंगे चलो हमने इंस्टॉल तो कर लिया ये
अपग्रेड भी हो गया होगा मेरे ख्याल से चलो
यह भी हो ही रहा है ऑलमोस्ट चलो लेट इट
फिनिश जल्दी हो जाएगा इंटरनेट स्पीड सही
है हमारी सो इट शुड कंप्लीट ए अपडेट प
अपग्रेड टाइम टाइम प चला लिया करना आपके
पैकेजेस जो भी अपग्रेडेड नहीं है अपग्रेड
हो जाएंगे तो आप ही का भला हो जाएगा है ना
चलिए तो हमारा ये अपग्रेड वाला प्रोसेस
ऑलमोस्ट हो चुका है हां अब यहां पे पहले
हम देख लेते हैं एपीआई की कहां डालेंगे सब
फाइंडर का जब तुम सब फाइंडर को इंस्टॉल कर
लोगे तो होम डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
कर देना सारे हिडन फाइल्स आपको दिखने
लगेंगे जब हिडन फाइल्स दिखने लगेंगे तो
आना यहां पे एंड यहां चले जाना डॉट
कॉन्फिन में आओगे तो यहां तुम्हें देखो सब
फाइंडर नाम का
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री आपको मिल रही है एक
कॉन्ग डवा एए एक प्रोवाइडर कगवा कगवा एए
जब ओपन करोगे तो यहां पे यह इसकी कॉन्फिन
की एक फाइल आपको दिख रही होगी कोई बात
नहीं एक प्रोवाइडर प्रोवाइडर कॉन्फिन
मिलेगी इसमें आपको यह सारे सर्विसेस जिसकी
एपीआई कीज आपको डालने हैं वह सारे यहां पे
दिखेंगे आपको यहीं पे एपीआई की इसके अंदर
आपको डाल देना है
दैट्ची ब्रैकेट दे रखा है इसके अंदर
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के अंदर आप एपीआई की डाल
दीजिए चलिए तो हम अब एपीआई की डालेंगे अब
देखो बिना एपीआई की और एपीआई की में क्या
डिफरेंसेस है मैं आपको पहले वो बताऊंगा ता
ताकि आपको बहुत ज्यादा क्लियर हो जाएगा
मतलब बहुत क्लियर हो जाएगा चलिए सबसे पहले
ना सब फाइंडर का हम यूज़ करते हैं फाइंड
करने के लिए आई होप कि ये तो अब हो गया
होगा चलिए ये भी हो गया है बहुत बढ़िया
ओके सब फाइंडर हान h कैसे यूज़ करना है
इसको भैया तो सब फाइंडर यूज़ करना है सब
फाइंडर देना है उसके बाद h d देना है
डोमेन के लिए
tesla.svs
की आपको सब डोमेन फाइंड करके देगा ये बहुत
अच्छी चीज है उसके बाद h s अगर आपको लाइक
कोई स्पेसिफिक सोर्स यूज़ करना है जैसे गब
सीटीएस जो भी सोर्स के लिस्ट है तो आप हाफ
s लगा सकते हैं अदर वाइज छोड़ दीजिए कोई
दिक्कत नहीं उसके बाद नीचे आ जाइए हान ऑल
यूज ऑल सोर्सेस फॉर न्यूमरेशन जितने
सोर्सेस है सबको यूज़ करेगा थोड़ा स्लो
होगा बट सबको यूज़ करेगा ये भी अच्छी बात
है सबको हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं हान ए m मैच
स्ट्रिंग सब डोमेन और लिस्ट ऑफ सब डोमेन
टू मैच अगर कोई मैचिंग स्ट्रिंग डालनी है
वो कर सकते हैं ठीक है ना ये फिल्टर ल्टर
लगाने के लिए कर सकते हैं रेट लिमिट वगैरह
जो है वो डिफाइन कर सकते हैं मैक्सिमम
कितने रिक्वेस्ट जाएंगे आपके ये सारी
चीजें कर सकते हैं आउटपुट
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
एक्सिसिली मेंशन भी कर सकते हैं भाई
कॉन्फिन फाइल्स को हान कॉन्फिन लगा के अदर
वाइज ये ऑटो डिटेक्ट भी कर लेता है इसके
डायरेक्टरी में
कॉन्फिडेंस के बाद हान v से वर्वस आउटपुट
आपको दिख जाएगा सिंपल सी चीज है और तो कुछ
है नहीं इसमें ज्यादा
अ या नथिंग
एल्स हाई फन एनसी कर दोगे डिबल कलर कलर को
डिसेबल कर देगा कोई जरूरत है नहीं भैया
चलिए तो हम क्या करते हैं सब फाइंडर
नडी
tesla.svs
सबको समझ में आ रहा है चलिए अगर समझ में आ
रहा है अच्छी बात है तो h
tesla.svs हमें आउटपुट मिल गया यहां
पे ठीक है 662 सब डोमन फॉर
tesla.svs
को डिजिटो उस को यूज़ किया सीआरटी एसए से
इसने फाइंड किया एनू बिस से किने फाइंड
किया अभी और दिखाता
हूं चलिए ऊपर चलते हैं और भी इसके सोर्सेस
देखते हैं कहां-कहां से इन भैया ने हमें
सब डोमस फाइंड करके दिए हैं सीआरटीएस
अगेन ओके सीआरटीएस ठीक है क्या है ये
व्हाट इज दिस कैन नॉट यूज द सीना सोर्स
हां देखो जब हमने ये किया तो यहां पे क्या
आ रहा है देखो कैन नॉट यूज द क्वेक सोर्स
बिकॉज देयर वाज नो एपीआई की कैन नॉट यूज द
वेगल बिकॉज दे नो एपीआई की अब इनको ये यूज
नहीं कर पा रहे क्योंकि एपीआई की ही नहीं
है भैया एपीआई की नहीं है इसलिए हमें
कितने सब डोमस का आउटपुट मिले ये हमें एक
फाइल में आ गई होगी देखो
tesla.svs व्यू कर दो और सबसे नीचे चले
जाओ और देख लो कितने सब डोमस है कितने 662
है ठीक है बट अगर मान लो लाइन नंबर नहीं
है मान लो किसी ऐसी टेक्स्ट एडिटर में हो
जहां लाइन नंबर नहीं है वहां पे क्या
करोगे क्या तरीका यूज करोगे तो हमें फाइल
का नाम तो पता है
tesla.svs
whatsapp.in यह पाइप का मतलब क्या है भाई
बताना जरा
बताना पाइप का नाम पाइप का मतलब क्या है
बताओ जरा पाइप पाइप क्यों देते हैं भाई
किसी को पता है सबने जिसने करी होगी यार
उसको पता होगा नहीं करी होगी नहीं पता
होगा सिंपल से फंडा है
यार पाइप का पाइप
का पाइप का मतलब यहां पाइप जब लगा दोगे
उसके बाद एक दूसरा कमांड वर्ड काउंट हम
करेंगे एंड उसको लिस्ट करेंगे डब्लू स
हाइन एल वर्ड काउंट को हम लिस्ट करेंगे
बेसिकली यानी काउंट करेंगे और लिस्ट
करेंगे क्या होता है कि जो ये पाइप आप
लगाते हो भैया पाइप लगाते हो तो आप पहला
जो कमांड है उसके आउटपुट को एज अ इनपुट
लेते हो दूसरे कमांड में इसका मतलब सिंपल
यही है पहले इस कमांड को एग्जीक्यूट करो
और उस पे ये कमांड अप्लाई करो यानी इसका
आउटपुट क्या होगा इसका आउटपुट जितने सब
डोमेन से है वो होगा और उसको तुरंत
डब्ल्यू सफन l में ले जाओ उसको काउंट कर
लो और उसको लिस्ट कर दो सिंपल एंटर करो 6
62 600 62 सब डोमेंस इस तरीके से आप कर
सकते हैं गट
इट ग्रेप करने के लिए नहीं होता मेरे भाई
ग्रेप इज डिफरेंट थिंग इसलिए तो बोलता हूं
कांसेप्ट को क्लियर करो ग्रेप इज अ
डिफरेंट थिंग ठीक है फॉर रन यह देखो भाई
ये अलग ही है रन क्या होता है भाई ग्रेप
इज अ डिफरेंट थिंग ठीक है तो थोड़ा आप
समझो यह इस कमांड के इनपुट को उसमें
आउटपुट देता है समझ में आ रहा
है
पहले कमांड के इनपुट को दूसरे में पहले
कमांड के आउटपुट को दूसरे में इनपुट देता
है गॉट
इट चलिए तो हमने यहां पे काउंट कर लिया अब
हम क्या करते हैं सेम आपके सामने सब कुछ
है यहां पे सब कुछ आपको कर दिया अब हम
एपीआई कॉन्फिन करते हैं और फिर रिजल्ट में
डिफरेंस देखते हैं जो डिफरेंस है ना दिमाग
खराब हो जाएगा तुम्हारा डिफरेंस देख के
चलो कॉन्फिन हैं शोडाउन नहीं सब फाइंडर
में चलते हैं प्रोवाइडर कगवा इसमें चलते
हैं अब इसमें ना कुछ हम एपीआई की कुछ ही
कन्फ करता अब इतने सारे एी तो अभी बैठ के
करेंगे नहीं नहीं यार तो इसको थोड़ा बड़ा
नहीं हो सकता क्या
यार सेलेक्ट
फॉन्ट बड़ा करो यार बहुत छोटा है 13 14 15
18 19 20 20 पे कर हां चलो तो अब हम इसमें
सारे में करेंगे तो करते रह जाएंगे ठीक है
तो हम थोड़े बहुत में कर लेते हैं कन्फर
जैसे कि वायरस टोटल इसका इसका हम कर सकते
हैं जल्दी से क्योंकि शायद इस पे काउंट
होगा मेरे ख्याल से चलिए वायरस टोटल ओपन
कर लेते हैं वायरस टोटल लेट्स ओपन इट उसके
बाद शोडाउन शोडाउन को भी ओपन कर लेते हैं
शोडाउन लेट्स ओपन इट अरे यार लॉगिन है
क्या अरे चलो बहुत बढ़िया ऑलरेडी लॉगइन है
हमारा शोडाउन पे चल लेते हैं अब यार एपीआई
की यार ठीक है मैं एपीआई की पे चल देता
हूं मुझे एपीआई की जनरेट मैं दूसरी री
जनरेट कर दूंगा एपीआई की कोई टेंशन नहीं
है यहां पे साइन इन पे चलते हैं वायरस
टोटल पे आएंगे साइन इन करेंगे तो हम यहां
पे
अरे कोई सा भी कर लेता हूं मैं एक ग
अकाउंट यूज कर लेता हूं एंड इससे लॉगइन कर
लेता हूं शान में अरे यार य लग आउट हो गया
है
ओके लेट्स लॉग इन विथ ए लॉग इन टू सडन एंड
सडन का लॉगिन जो है ना यार वो मुझे लॉगिन
आई थिंक आया हुआ था तो व लॉगिन ऑलरेडी जो
लॉगिन वाला पासवर्ड था शायद वही यूज करना
पड़ेगा मुझे तो लेट मी सी द लॉगइन पासवर्ड
क्या लगन पासवर्ड था यार मुझे याद भी नहीं
आ रहा है अब
तो लेट्स
वेट
ओके हा शो डान तो मैं इसका पासवर्ड यहां
से मुझे देखना पड़ेगा एंड देन यूज करना
पड़ेगा ओ क्या पासवर्ड है यार चलो मैं
यहां पर पासवर्ड टाइप कर देता
हूं
अब यह क्या है यह तो पता नहीं कौन
ये या आई और एल का बड़ा ंट होता है यह तो
मैंने देखा
है ओके यह क्या है
यह आई डोंट नो क्या है आई एल है बट ठीक है
व्ट एवर एक बार कर लेते हैं देख लेते
हैं
चलिए लॉगइन करके देखते हैं गड़बड़ होगा तो
वही एक ही होगा चलो हो गया लॉगइन चलो बहुत
बढ़िया बात है अकाउंट प चलते हैं एंड यहां
पे एपीआई की आपको दिख रहा होगा ये एपीआई
की ठीक है मेरे को अभी मैं शो कर देता हूं
बट बाद में मुझे इसको रिमूव करना पड़ेगा
तो अभी के लिए मैं आपको भी दिखा देता हूं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है मैंने यहां पे एपीआई
की क्या किया कॉपी कर लिया अब मैं बाद में
इसको रिसेट मार दूंगा ठीक है अब मैं यहां
पे
अ वायरस टोटल वाली जो एपीआई की है इसको
यहां पर हमने पेस्ट कर दिया चलिए एक एपीआई
की हमारी
कॉन्फिडो की नहीं ये तो वायरस टोटल की
नहीं थी ना यार ये तो सडन की थी
यार यह तो हमारा शोडाउन का था भाई शोडाउन
का तो हमने शोडाउन वाली एपीआई की यहां पे
कंफिल कर दी चलिए हमने सोडा की एपीआई की
तो कर दी अब चलते हैं वायरस टोटल पे यह
क्या हुआ
भाई हो जा भाई लॉगिन क्या दिक्कत क्या आ
रही है वायरस टोटल
में क्या रहा है
ये अजीब बात
है अजीब बात है फारस टोटल इ नॉट गेटिंग
लगड इन तो एक काम करते हैं साइन अप करने
की कोशिश करते हैं
इसमें इसलिए शायद नाराज
होगा सेम उससे साइन अप नहीं होगी
शायद कंटिन्यू विथ
कर लो भाई क्या दिक्कत क्या आ रही है
तुम्हें लेट्स ट्राई विद
ग
ओके नहीं अगर काम कर रहा है कोई टेंशन
नहीं है कोई टेंशन नहीं है मत लो कोई
टेंशन मत लो जो काम कर रहा उसको यूज करो
यार कौन काम कर रहा है नहीं कर रहा उससे
क्या मतलब है जो काम करर उसको उसको यूज
करो ना इससे देख लेते
हैं
ओके सो डू वन थिंग यहां पर चलते हैं वायरस
टोटल पर चलते हैं लेट्स ट्राई टू लॉग इन
यर यहां पर देखते हैं लॉगइन
करके शायद यहां पर पहले से पता आई थंक
पहले से नहीं होगा शायद मे
बी लेट्स ट्राई टू लॉग इन हियर ऑन दिस
पेज यह हो जाना चाहिए हां चलो यह हो गया
चलिए वायरस टोटल का भी आ गया यहां पे आप
जाएंगे सेटिंग प एपीआई की प आप आएंगे एंड
यहां पे एपीआई की आपको मिल जाएगी कॉपी कर
लीजिए एपीआई की को एंड यहां पे वायरस टोटल
वाली जगह पे यहां पे आपने पेस्ट कर दिया
है वायरस टोटल भी हो गया सडन भी हो गया और
भी और भी जो भी है आप कर सकते हैं जूम आई
प भी कर सकते हैं जूम आई प जाके वहां भी
अकाउंट वो करके आप क्रिएट कर सकते हैं इफ
यू वांट जस्ट गो टू द जम आई जम
आई
जम आई पर चलते
हैं एंड सिमिलर है यहां पर भी वही है सेम
चीज है आपको अकाउंट बनाना है लॉग इन करना
है अकाउंट सेक्शन में जाइएगा वहां एपीआई
की आपको दिख जाएगी या डेवलपर सेक्शन होता
है डेवलपर ऑप्शन होगा वहां पर चले जाइएगा
वहां प एपीआई की मिल जाएगी हम मेरा मेन
मोटिव जो है आपको बताना कि एपीआई की आपको
कहां से मिलेगी गिब का भी एपीआई की बहुत
आसान
है गिट हब गिट पर चलते हैं शायद पता नहीं
यहां पर आ जाइएगा यहां
प अगेन यहां पर आपको जूम आई प भी लॉगइन
करना पड़ जाएगा आई होप सो कि ग लॉग इन हो
आसान होता है थोड़ा सा ओके यहां पर तो
शायद नहीं है लॉगिन यहां
प ओ गिट प लॉगइन करना पड़ेगा ब छोड़ देते
रह देते हैं यहां पर आ जाते
हैं ओके अ सोशल लॉगिन ये कौन सा लॉगिन
सिस्टम है भाई सोशल का य
कि जितने ज्यादा रिसोर्सेस के एपीआई की
तुम डालोगे उतने ज्यादा सब डोमेंस मिलेंगे
और उतने ज्यादा तुम्हारे स्कोप का अ स्कोप
इंक्रीज होगा और उतना ज्यादा तुम्हें
वैलिड बग मिलने के चांसेस बढ़ते जाएंगे
एंड अच्छे खासे तुम्हें बग्स मिलने शुरू
हो जाएंगे इतना जान लो तुम जितना ज्यादा
एपीआई कंफिल करोगे जितनी सर्विसेस की जो
वो टूल यूज करता है पर्टिकुलर उतना
तुम्हारे लिए बेनिफिशियल रहेगा चलिए ये
ओपन हो रहा है गिट हप का तो मुझे आई थिंक
मेरे पास एक गिट अप का होगा अकाउंट का बट
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं है तो यहां पे हम जम
आई में आ चुके हैं एंड यहां पे कहीं ना
कहीं आपको एक मिलेगी क्या
अ लाइक व्हाट व्हाट एपीआई की तो ये एपीआई
की यहां से मैं कॉपी कर लेता हूं जम आई की
तो मैं यहां से जम आई की एपीआई की हमने
कॉपी कर ली एंड जम आई की एपीआई की हमने
यहां पे पेस्ट कर दी तो हमने क्या किया
बेसिकली तीन सर्विस की एपीआई की बस डाली
है यहां पे इसको सेव कर देते हैं अगेन एंड
इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं बस हमने बस तीन
सर्विस तीन एपीआई कीज हमने कंफिल करी है
सर्विसेस की एंड
दैट्ची 62 मिला था अब हम वापस से टेस्ला
की सब डोमेन फाइंड सॉरी इसको कैंसिल
करो नाउ वापस से हम टेस्ला के सब डोमेन
फाइंड करेंगे सब फाइंडर
से सॉरी मैं इसको थोड़ा जूम कर लेता हूं
क्या हुआ
ये इसको जूम कर लेता हूं सब फाइंडर
अ ठीक है नडी
टेस्ला कॉ ठीक है h o एंड इस बार करते हैं
ला एआई सबड t एकटी सब डोमेन का लिस्ट एंड
हाइन v लगा देते हैं वर्वस आउटपुट के लिए
टेस्ला एपीआई सब अब हम इसको एंटर करते हैं
एंड नाउ लेट्स ट्राई एंड लेट्स सी हाउ
मेनी सब डोमेंस वी आर गोइंग टू गेट जस्ट
बाय इंक्रीजिंग द कन्फेशन टू द थ्री एपीआई
की यह देखिए 600 कुछ सब डोमेन मिले थे
आपको यहां कितने सब डोमेन मिले हैं 101 सब
डोमेन 1011 सब डोमेन फाइल आपकी बन के
तैयार र हो गई भाई टेस्ला एपीआई सब और
टेस्ला कितने मिले भैया 111 चलो इसको कैट
कर लेते हैं कैट टेस्ला एपीआई सबड एक्सटी
वर्ड काउंट
लिस्ट
101 समझ में आ गया यह डिफरेंस तुमको समझ
में आया सिर्फ तीन ही सर्विसेस की हमने
एपीआई की अभी डाली अभी तो सबकी डाली भी
नहीं यार सिर्फ तीन की डाली हमने यू गट
एवरीवन
गट एव गॉट समझ में आ रहा है ये डिफरेंस
समझ में आ रहा है एपीआई की कहां कंफिल
करनी है रूट में या होम
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
से यू आर गोइंग टू गेट अ लॉट लॉट ऑफ सब
डोमेंस जहां पर आपको थोड़े कम मिलने हैं
वहां ज्यादा मिलेंगे जहा जहां और कम है
वहा और ज्यादा मिले मतलब जितना एपीआई
कॉन्फिडो और मजे लेते जाओ एपीआई कन्फर करो
मजे लो बिना एपीआई कॉन्फिन के नहीं होने
वाला है यह बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है एपीआई को
कन्फर करना 101 सब डोमेंस हमें यहां पर
मिले हैं तो चलिए तीन एपीआई हमने किया हम
तीन एपीआई को फिलहाल यूज करने वाले हैं तो
हमारे पास ये टेस्ला इस वाले को पहले वाले
को देखो तुम्हें एक चीज बताता हूं यहां पे
दो सब डोमस की लिस्ट है यहां पे यू हैव टू
सब डोमेंस लिस्ट एक ये और एक ये है अब
मुझे क्या करना है ना भैया कि मुझे एक ही
लिस्ट चाहिए मैं क्या कर देता हूं ला सब .
txa2 थे कुछ और बढ़ जाएंगे इसको इसको
मैंने कॉपी पेस्ट कर दिया मैंने इसको सेव
कर दिया एंड इसको क्लोज कर दिया पहले वाला
जो लिस्ट उसको डिलीट करया जो 600 वाला था
मेरे पास सिर्फ एक लिस्ट पड़ी है इसको मैं
रिनेम कर देता हूं क्या कर देता हूं
[संगीत]
टेस्ला टेस्ला सबड t
एकटी यह हमने इसको रिनेम कर दिया चलिए
बहुत बढ़िया बात है यहां पे एंड यहां पे
चलिए लाटी हमने रिनेम कर दिया अब हम यहां
पे ओपन कर लेते हैं अब हम इसको कैट करके
देखते हैं इसमें कितने कटला
सबड हान एल और हमारे पास 1674 सब डोमस है
अब मुझे मान लो इसमें मुझे लग रहा है कुछ
डुप्लीकेट सब डोमेन भी है वी हैव सम
डुप्लीकेट सब डोमेन लेट्स सपोज अब मुझे
उनको फाइंड करना है यह कैसे करेंगे भाई
इसके लिए भी एक कमांड है डुप्लीकेट्स को
रिमूव करना है क्या कैसे कैसे करेंगे क्या
कमांड है भैया इसके लिए तो शॉर्ट कमांड का
यूज
करेंगे शॉर्ट कमांड का यूज कर सकते हो कैट
में शर्ट पास कर सकते हो और न्यू कमांड का
यूज कर सकते हो दे मल्टीपल वे ठीक है
शॉर्ट कमांड यूज करेंगे शॉर्ट हो गया ठीक
है अब क्या करेंगे फाइल जो फाइल चाहिए तो
टेस्ला सबड एक्सटी उसके बाद यहां पर पाइप
लगाएंगे इसके आउटपुट को कहां ले जाना है
एक दूसरे कमांड के इनपुट में दे देना है
यूनिक यूनिक ये और लिस्ट देखनी है कि
कितने सारे
आपके आपके क्या है यूनिक है मतलब कितने
सारे डुप्लीकेट्स हैं तो हाइन डी यह लगा
दीजिए और एंटर कीजिए एंड देखिए आपको कुछ
लिस्ट मिल जाएंगी जो कि डुप्लीकेट एंट्रीज
हैं इसके अंदर में तो ये आप देखिए यहां पे
अगर आपको यूनिक वाले निकालने हैं मान लो
सारे यूनिक वाले फाइंड करने हैं तो यहां
पे यूनिक ये कीवर्ड रहने दीजिए एंड यहां
पे
एक स्टडी यूज कीजिए आउट का एंड यहां पे पे
आप क्या कीजिए एक नया फाइल जनरेट कीजिए
जिसमें यूनिक सब डोमेंस आपको मिल जाएंगे
जो भी यूनिक सब डोमेंस है वो सारे आपके
उसमें आ जाएंगे तो चलिए कितने यूनिक निकाल
दिया हमने यहां पे यूनिक अब मान लो डब्लू
स हाइ
फनल 1012 1600 थे उसमें से 600 कुछ के
आसपास जो हैं वो निकल गए आपके जो भी अ
डुप्लीकेट्स थे वो निकल गए और आपको यूनिक
वाले आपको मिल चुके हैं तो इसको हम फाइनल
एक लिस्ट में डाल देते हैं यूनिक करके एंड
यहां पे इसको कहां पे डाल देते हैं अ
tesla.svs
10122 जो है वो आपको दिख जाएंगे कि 1012
सब डोमस हमारे पास मिल चुके हैं तो पहला
वाला फिर से डिलीट कर देते हैं हमारे पास
tesla.svs लिस्ट यहां पे आ चुकी है यह हो
गया एक सब डोमेन फाइंड करने का एक टूल का
यूज़ करके सब फाइंडर इतना आई होप कि सब
लोगों को क्लियर हो चुका होगा अब चलिए अब
यहां बात करते हैं मल्ट अब हमें क्या करना
है ना यार हमें मल्टीपल टूल्स से मल्टीपल
सब डोमेंस फाइंड करने हैं एंड उनकी एक
पूरी लिस्ट बनानी है उस पे लाइव लाइव या
लाइव है या नहीं है यह ट्राई यह देखना है
यह चीज करनी है यह सारी चीज करनी है
वो कैसे करेंगे अब हम दूसरा टूल यूज
करेंगे एक और टूल हमारा शानदार टूल जिसका
नाम है ए
मैस दिस इज ए मैस टूल जब आप जाएंगे ए मैस
किट हब सॉरी
सॉरी
सॉरी ओके ओस प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर अब आ चुका
है ये टूल ए मैस आपका इसका गेट अप
रिपोजिटरी आपको यहां मिल जाएगा बट अगेन
काली यूज करते हैं तो आपकी बल्ले बल्ले
हैं भैया काली में आपको एप्ट लिस्ट करेंगे
ए मैस आपको रिपोजिटरी में मिल जाएगा एंड
इन फैक्ट आपके रिपोजिटरी में से आप इसको
डायरेक्टली इंस्टॉल कर लेंगे एट इंस्टॉल
कमांड से ए मैस और जैसे इंस्टॉल कर लेंगे
यह इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा अगर इंस्टॉल है
ऑलरेडी तो यू आर गुड टू गो हेल्प फाइल
देखनी है भैया एस h h एंटर करेंगे इसकी
आपको हेल्प फाइल दिख जाएगी इसमें आपको
दिखेगा एस
ल इंफॉर्मेशन वाली वीडियो रेकन की स्टार्ट
की थी हमने तो उसमें हमने
कॉन्फिन करेंगे भैया ठीक है बिना उसके
नहीं चलेगा काम चलिए ये लिंक मैंने ओपन कर
दिया चलो मैं इसमें ओपन कर देता हूं ताकि
क्लियर आपको
दिखेगा विज होस्ट वाले में
ओके ये एग्जांपल एपी एग्जांपल कॉन्फिन
फाइल है भैया ठीक है कोई बात नहीं अब इस
कॉन्फिन फाइल में आपको कहीं एपीआई की
डालने का कुछ नहीं दिख रहा होगा ये सिंपल
सा फाइल है ये ठीक है कुछ आपको ज्यादा कुछ
नहीं दिख रहा यहां पे एक डटा सोर्सड y एए
फाइल है और एक config.yml फाइल है ये
दोनों फाइल आपको यूज करनी है और आपको इसके
कॉन्फिन एस के कंफिल करना है डाटा सोर्स
में आप आएंगे तो यहां देखेंगे आप अलग-अलग
सर्विसेस जो यह यूज़ करता है एंड उसकी
एपीआई की डालने की जगह दी हुई है समझ में
आ गया तोब यह दोनों फाइल मुझे चाहिए भाई
तो config.yml इसको भी लेना है चलिए काली
में ही चलते हैं काली से ही यहां से उठा
लेते हैं तो config.yml यह फाइल है इसको
हम क्या करते हैं डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं
पहले डाउनलोड हो गई डेटा सडवा इसको भी हम
क्या कर देते हैं डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं
चलिए डाउनलोड हो
गई हां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल दोनों फाइल डाउनलोड हो गई लाइव
में ज्यादा मजा आता है है ना मजा आता है
ना शेयर शेयर तो करते हो ना भाई शेयर करते
हो कि नहीं करते हो अपने दोस्तों के बीच
यह तो बता दो शेयर तो कर दिया करना यार
चलिए यह दोनों चीज आ गई दोनों फाइल अब इस
दोनों फाइल को यहां से भैया करना है कॉपी
क्या करना है कॉपी कॉपी करके इनको ले जाना
है कहां पर होम फोल्ड में जाना है यहां
जाना है आपको कॉन्फिन की डायरेक्टरी है
इसमें चले जाना और यहां पे पेस्ट मार देना
ये ऑटोमेटिक एमएस इस
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
गेशन आ चुकी है अब यहां पे कॉन्फिन जो
हमने फाइल है इसमें हमने कॉन्फिन में
एपीआई की करना है टा सोर्सेस y एए वाले
में फाइल में यहां आ जाइए अब यहां आएंगे
तो डटा सोर्स में क्या है 360 पैसिव
डीएनएस इसका नहीं हमारे पास अभी आप लोग
जितने मैक्सिमम कर सकते हैं एपीआई की सेट
कर दीजिएगा बस इतना ही बोलूंगा तो हमारे
पास तीन थे हम तीनों एपीआई की यहां पे उठा
के डाल देते हैं तो हमारे तीनों एपीआई कीज
[संगीत]
अ कहां थे भैया हमारे सब फाइंडर में थे सब
फाइंडर में चलिए प्रोवाइडर्स इसमें चलते
हैं शान पहले शान वाला भाई जो हमारा फाइल
है इसको कॉपी करते
हैं डाटा सोर्स में आते हैं एंड शोडाउन
शोडाउन कहां गया शोडाउन शोडाउन शोडाउन
शोडाउन शोडाउन होगा तो सही यार शोडाउन यह
रहा यह रहा शोडाउन एपीआई की नल है यहां
क्यों भाई नल क्यों रहोगे यार तुम
तुम्हारे तुम्हें को मैं एपी की दे रहा
हूं ना एपी की हमने डाल दिया शोडाउन का
चलिए अब यहां चलते हैं वायर स्टेट वायरस
टेटल बोल रहा हूं वायरस टोटल वाला भी उठा
लेते
हैं वायरस टोटल ये रहा नल ना रे नल नहीं
होना भाई नल ले थोड़ी ना हो तुम नल यहां
पर हमने नल वाला भी डाल दिया अब आ जाते
हैं जूम आई जूम आई भी हमने निकाल ही लिया
था तो इसको भी निकाल ही लेते हैं भैया जम
आई यह रहा जूम आई जूम आई सबसे लास्ट ही है
ओके जू आई के लिए दे आर आस्किंग यूजर नेम
एंड पासवर्ड यूजर नेम एंड पासवर्ड मांग
रहे लिटरली भाई दिस इज नॉट अ गुड थिंग
एपीआई की से हो जाना चाहिए था बट ठीक है
कोई बात नहीं हम इसको छोड़ देंगे सिंपल हम
दो ही को कन्फर करेंगे वायरस टोटल एंड
हमारा जो हो गया एक शोडाउन कन्फर किया
यहां पे सेव कर दिया
दैट्ची
हान एच हमें एन्यूमरेशन करना है एनम एनम
ठीक है तो हम क्या करेंगे एमस और एनम
लिखेंगे और तब इसकी हाइफ एच देंगे इसकी
हेल्प फाइल देखने के लिए कि अब एस एनम के
अंदर हम कितनी सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं यह
हमें देखना है तो चलिए हम आ चुके हैं
अच्छा आप में से कितने लोग बोर हो रहे हैं
जल्दी बता
दीजिए आप में से कितने लोग बोर हो रहे
हैं
आहा बताइए कितने लोग बोर हो रहे हैं आप
में
से लेट्स सी सबके नाम देखता हूं मैं कितने
लोग बोर हो रहे हैं और कितने लोगों को मजा
आ रहा है देखता हूं मैं कितने लोग हैं भाई
[संगीत]
चलिए
बोर नहीं हो रहा क्या कोई तो हो ही रहा
होगा यार एक दो तो हो ही रहा
होगा एक दो तो बंदे बोर हो ही रहे होंगे
यार कोई नहीं हो रहा क्या
कोई देख रहा हूं मैं चैट बिल्कुल भी नहीं
बहुत मजा आ रहा है बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया
एक्साइटमेंट नॉट गेटिंग बोर्ड
बढ़िया
एपीआई सेट क्यों नहीं हो रही यार एपीआई
सेट तो हो ही
जाएगी चलिए ठीक है जहां पे देखो जहां पे
आपको एपीआई की डालने की है एपीआई की डाल
दीजिएगा जहां यूजरनेम पासवर्ड का है
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड डाल दीजिएगा हर बार कुछ
ना कुछ चेंजेज होते रहते हैं अलग-अलग तरह
की चीजें होती है कॉन्फिन की चीजें होती
हैं तो ऐसा नहीं है कि आपका एपीआई की ही
यूज़ होगा या यूजर नेम पासवर्ड ही यूज़
होगा जहां जो रिक्वायरमेंट है वहां दे
दीजिएगा वहां वो यूज़ होने लगेगा खुद के
भी एपीआई की आप एमस में क्या है ना एस में
आप खुद का एक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल भी बना
सकते हैं ठीक है खुद का सॉरी एक कॉन्फिन
फाइल बना सकते हैं उस कॉन्फिन फाइल को आप
एक कॉन्फिन
के आर्गुमेंट को या ऑप्शन को पास करके
उसको डिफाइन कर सकते हैं देखिए हाइन
कॉन्फिन टू द वाईएमएल कॉन्फिन फाइल जो भी
आपकी वामल कॉन्फिन फाइल है उसको हाइन
कॉफिको पाथ दे दीजिए वहां से ही ये रीड कर
लेगा अदर वाइज जो
कॉन्फिडो मेेली रीड करेगा
चलिए अब क्या करते हैं एमएस हमने क्या
किया ए मैस यहां पे दिया चलिए ए मैस दिया
अब इसके बाद क्या कमांड डालना है एनम
क्योंकि हम एमरेड कर रहे हैं तो ओबवियसली
एनम तो हमारा रहेगा ही रहेगा ठीक है सभी
लोग कीजिए साथ में बढ़िया रहेगा उसके बाद
हम यहां पे करते
हैं आपको एक्टिव स्कैनिंग करनी है या
न्यूमरेशन करनी है या पैसिव करनी है हमें
फिलहाल अभी ना एक्टिव नहीं करनी हमें
पैसिव करना है थोड़ा फास्ट करना है हमें
और पैसिव वाला ऑप्शन यूज करना है आपको तो
यहां पे आपको पैसिव भी मिल जाएगा ऑप्शन
देख लीजिए कहीं पे ये हाइफ एन पैसिव ठीक
है ठीक है हाइफ एन पैसिव यह हालांकि
डिफॉल्ट है तो आप इसको लगाइए नहीं लगाइए
आपकी मर्जी है लेकिन मैं लगा देता हूं
हाइन पैसिव ये डिफॉल्ट है लगाइए ना लगाइए
ये रहेगा आपका अगर आप एक्टिव नहीं लगा रहे
तो हाइन पैसिव ऑटोमेटिक ये डिफॉल्ट लगा
रहेगा ठीक है भैया तो हमने हाइन पैसिव कर
दिया अब यहां पे क्या करना है यहां पे
हमें हाइन डी डोमेन चलिए डोमेन लगा देते
हैं नडी से डोमेन नडी टेस्ला tesla.svs तो
हमने यहां पे डोमेन भी दे दिया अब यहां पे
भाई आपको ऑप्शंस कौन-कौन मेरे साथ कर रहा
है बताओ जरा जल्दी कौन-कौन मेरे साथ कर
रहा है बताओ मुझे अब यहां पे हमें ऑप्शंस
देना है तो अगर कॉन्फिन फाइल मेंशन करनी
है तो मेंशन कर दीजिए अदर वाइज हमने
ऑलरेडी डाला हुआ है तो डिटेक्ट हो जाना
चाहिए तो हमने क्या किया डोमेन दे दिया अब
हमें इसके रिजल्ट्स अगर मान लो मान
लो मान लो हमें रिजल्ट्स चाहिए आउटपुट
चाहिए किसी एक पर्टिकुलर फाइल में तो वो
फाइल आपको मेंशन करनी है सिंपल सी चीज है
ठीक है तो यहां पे हम क्या करते हैं हान ओ
पाथ टू अ टेक्स्ट फाइल कंटेनिंग द आउटपुट
ठीक है तो हमने न o लगा देना है तो चलिए
मैं यहां पे न o लगा देता हूं एंड यहां पे
एक आउटपुट फाइल दे देता हूं क्या ला a.txt
एस वाली जितनी भी हमारी डोमेन है वो सबको
हम यहां पे
tesla.svs
करना है आपको तो ये हम बाद में देखेंगे
अभी जरूरत आपकी नहीं है ठीक
है हां आप डीएनएस रिजॉल्वर्स यूज कर रहे
हैं आप कर सकते हैं हान टी लगा के लाइक
जिससे कि आपका बैन होने का ब्लॉक होने का
रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो चांस थोड़ा कम हो जाता
है रिजॉल्वर्स यूज होते हैं वहां पे अभी
के लिए इसको रहने देते हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है हम पैसिव वैसे भी यूज करें एक्टिव
में उसका यूज आप कर सकते हैं एक्टिव जब आप
मोड यूज करेंगे तो ठीक है अ ठीक है हान r
लगा के आप आईपी एड्रेस कर सकते हैं
अनट्रस्टेड डीएनएस रिजॉल्वर्स के लिए बाकी
तो कोई चीज है नहीं पोर्ट नंबर भी आप
मेंशन कर सकते हैं अगर आप चाहते हैं कोई
डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट के ही आउटपुट आपको मिले कि
जो उस पोर्ट के वाले ही सब डोमस आपको ये
फाइंड करके दे 80 या 443 यूजुअली यही होते
हैं तो आप पोर्ट वाला मेंशन कर सकते हैं
हान p अदर वाइज आप इसको छोड़ सकते हैं कोई
टेंशन नहीं है चलिए तो हमने यह कर दिया अब
हम यहां पे एंटर करेंगे एंड लेट्स फाइंड
आउट व्हाट वी आर गेटिंग तो हमने कर दिया
एंड वी आर वेटिंग फॉर द
रिजल्ट्स थोड़ा एमएस स्लो काम करता है
लोकल सिस्टम पे जब आप इसको क्लाउड में यूज
करेंगे तो बहुत शानदार काम करता है यकीन
मानिए तो हमने यह चला दिया
tesla.svs
द सब डोम तो आप देख सकते यहां पर इट इज
नाउ ट्राइट गिव ऑल द सब डोम देखिए य पर
देखते
जाइए देखते
जाइए सर्चिंग
सर्चिंग
सॉरी इट्स स्टिल गिविंग यू द रिजल्ट स्टिल
गिविंग यू द
रिजल्ट ठीक
है किसी वेबसाइट पर करो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है किसी वेबसाइट पर करो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है और लाइक ठोक दो यार लाइक तो ठोका ही
नहीं आप लोगों ने लाइक तो बहुत कम है भाई
लाइक और आ सकते हैं बता दीजिए और कुछ है
आपके पास जादू लाइक लाने के तो बताइए एंड
तब तक मैं यहां पे इसको ओपन कर लेता हूं
लेट्स ओपन इट ताकि मैं एक और जो शेड्यूल
होती है क्लास उसको भी देख
लूं लेट मी
ओपन जस्ट वेट
गाइस
चलिए ओके ओके तो यहां पे ये अभी भी कर रहा
है अभी भी आपके रिजल्ट्स अ क्वेरी कर रहा
है तो इट विल लाइक इट विल टेक टाइम अगेन
एमएस इज अ वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल काफी
सारे रिजल्ट्स आपको बड़ी शानदार तरीके से
देता है तो आपके लिए काफी यूज़फुल है जो
सब डोमेंस आप लाइक अदर टूल से नहीं खोज
पाएंगे जल्दी आपको यह थोड़ा दे देता है
जल्द और भी डिक कर देता है सब फाइंडर भी
बहुत अच्छा है जितने ज्यादा आप उसमें लाइक
एपी की डाल दीजिए कन्फर कर दीजिए आपको
उतने ही रिकॉर्ड्स मिल जाएंगे सब फाइंडर
से भी ठीक
है
या विंटर का टाइम है तो चल जाता है पानी
की तो ऐसी कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं होती है
बट यहां पे आप देखिए यहां पे टेला एए वाली
फाइल बन रही है यहां पे और आपको यहां पे
यह फाइल जो है आपको मिलनी स्टार्ट हो गई
है इसके अंदर जो भी डिटेल्स है व आने
स्टार्ट हो गए हैं
ओके तो इस तरीके से ये निकालता है फाइल इस
तरीके से य आपको डोमस आपको प्रोवाइड करता
है बस अभी फिलहाल के लिए ये आपको यहां पे
इस तरीके से डोमस प्रोवाइड कर देता है ठीक
है ए मैस बट मैं आपको एक ही चीज बोलूंगा
कि जब आप यूज़ करेंगे तो सब फाइंडर को
मेनली आप यूज़ कीजिए दैट इज़ अ वेरी वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल सब फाइंडर बहुत अच्छा टूल
है सब फाइंडर सब फाइंडर बहुत ज्यादा यूज़
करते हैं लोग एंड उससे ही आप मोस्टली
चीजें यूज़ कर सकते हैं उसके भी सोर्सेस
वगैरह जितने हैं एमएस में भी वही ऑलमोस्ट
यूज़ होते हैं बहुत ज्यादा आपको डिफरेंस
देखने को नहीं मिलेगा तो ऑलवेज यूज़ अ सब
फाइंडर एट द प्रायोरिटी लेवल देन आप एमएस
वगैरह के लिए जा सकते हैं फिर दूसरे टूल
के लिए भी जा सकते हैं तो यह थोड़ा सा
टाइम लेगा इसमें तो फिलहाल के लिए इसको
मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं मैं आपको बस तरीके
फिलहाल बता रहा हूं तो तो इससे भी आप अने
सब डोमेन फाइंड कर
सॉरी
ओके ओके सॉरी गाइस सॉरी फॉर द
डिस्टरबेंस तो चलिए यह एमस से आपको सब सब
डोमेन फाइंड करने का समझ में आ गया एमस से
एमस से सब डोमेन फाइंड करने का समझ में आ
गया
एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी
नो ओके तो प्लीज लेट मी नो
गाइ अ ठीक है ओके यू गॉट ओके ठीक
है ओके चलिए तो एएस का तो यहां पे एएस से
आपने फाइंड कर लिया इसके अलावा देखो है
मल्टीपल टूल्स एक्चुअली में बहुत सारे
टूल्स हैं आप यूज कर सकते हो उनका आप एफएफ
यूएफ का भी इनफैक्ट यूज कर सकते हो सब
डोमेन फाइंड करने के लिए एंड वर्डलिस्ट का
यूज करके आप सब डोमेन फाइंड कर सकते हो
ठीक है ना तो ये भी एक टूल है एमस अ एमएस
के बाद आप यूएफ का भी ट्राई कर सकते हो यू
कैन ट्राई टू फाइंड सब डोमेन फ्रॉम दैट
थिंग आल्सो उसके बाद आप यू कैन गो एंड अ
ट्राई केस क्लाइंट कमांड जो है उसको भी आप
फाइंड कर सकते हो केस क्लाइंट कमांड इससे
भी आप सब डोमेन फाइंड कर सकते हो अब इसका
केस क्लाइंट का क्या मैं बता रहा हूं
देखिए मैं आपको मैंने आपको इसलिए यहां पे
लिख के भी रखा
होगा आप आइए यहां
पे कम टू हियर एंड जस्ट टाइप केस अ
क्लाइंट
गिट
हब ये हमने फाइंड किया ठीक है ये हमने
क्या किया यहां पे केस क्लाइंट यहां पे कर
दिया अब हम क्या करेंगे गाइस केस क्लाइंट
इसको हम यूज करने वाले हैं कैसे यूज करने
वाले हैं चलिए हम क्या करते हैं केस
क्लाइंट वाली जो है इसको ओपन कर लेते
हैं यहां पे हमने ओपन कर लिया यहां पे ठीक
है इसको इंस्टॉल करने का कैसे है कैसे
इसको इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं गाइस इस तरीके
से ये वाला कमांड यूज करना है गो इंस्टॉल
एंड इसको इंस्टॉल कर लेना है बट इसको
इंस्टॉल करने से पहले क्योंकि गो गो कमांड
का यूज हो रहा है तो आपको गो इंस्टॉल करना
पड़ेगा उसके लिए आपको पट इंस्टॉल गोलंग
गोलंग जो है गो लैंग्वेज आपको इंस्टॉल
करनी पड़ेगी अपनी काली में तभी जाके आप
इसको यूज कर पाएंगे यहां पे हमने रेपो
यहां नाम हमने गलत दे दिया गो लैंग है
यहां एंटर किया हमने एंड मेरा ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल इसलिए आ रहा है आपने इंस्टॉल कर
लेना है थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा इंस्टॉल हो
जाएगा उसके बाद आपको ये ये कमांड पेस्ट कर
देना है जो इन्होंने दिया हुआ है गो को गो
से इंस्टॉल करने का एंटर कर देना है इनके
गिट हप रिपोजिटरी से उसके बाद जो केस
क्लाइंट है वो इंस्टॉल आपका हो जाएगा केस
क्लाइंट सॉफ्टवेयर आपके काली
पे ठीक है लेट इट इंस्टॉल गाइस ओके जस्ट
वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट
ओके कितने लोग है यहां
पे ओके सो इट्स गेटिंग
इंस्टॉल्ड
ओके तो यह इंस्टॉल हो रहा
है चलिए लेट इट बी एंड यहां जब आप केस के
गिट हब रेपो पे आएंगे तो आपको यहां पर दिख
रहा होगा कि डोमेन टू फाइंड सब डोमेन फॉर
हाइन डी कमांड लगाइए एंड यह उस पर्टिकुलर
डोमेन के सब डोमेन को फाइंड करके आपको दे
देता है ठीक है अब एपीआई की अगर आपको
डालनी है तो आप एपीआई की कंफिल कर सकते
हैं केस का यहां पे जो कि आप इस पे जाएंगे
cloudy.pk
कॉपी इट रियली लेट्स सी क्योंकि ए की तो
आही नहीं
कुछ क्लोज कर लेते हैं यहां पे एंड आपको
यहां पे एपीआई की मिल जाएगी यहां प
बेसिकली हमने लॉगिन नहीं किया होगा
ओबवियसली य हमने लॉगिन नहीं किया लॉगिन
करके आपको एपीआई की मिल जाएगी आप एपीआई की
कंफिल सा इसका यूज कैसे करेंगे मैं आपको
तरीके बता देता हूं देखो केस का आई होप कि
इंस्टॉल हो गया होगा
ये हां जी हो गया यहां पे अब यहां पे सी
एच ए ओ एस के ओस लिख के हान एच लिखिए इसकी
हेल्प फाइल ओपन हो जाएगी बस आपको क्या
करना है केस h d एंड
tesla.svs
क्या अच्छा अच्छा अच्छा ठीक है न v स्मल v
होगा यहां पे एंटर कर देंगे यहां पर क्या
रहा है ऑथराइजेशन टोकन नॉट स्पेसिफाइड
क्योंकि हमने यहां पे केस का जो एपीआई की
है वोह कन्फर नहीं किया है वह इंपॉर्टेंट
है आपका उसके बिना आपका नहीं होगा तो यहां
पे प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी से आप एपीआई की भी
ले सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यह कोई
बड़ी बात नहीं है प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी पे
आइए एंड एपीआई की ले लीजिए जैसे कि मैं
यहां पे
एंड या वी गट इट यर यहां पर
की शायद हमें मिल जाएगी यस एपी की मिल गई
हमने यहां पर एपीआई की ले लिया और कैसे
इसको एक्सपोर्ट करना भाई यह वाला कमांड यह
वाला कमांड आपको क्या करना है कहां पर
करना है आपको अपने
बैश प्रोफाइल या जेडएस प्रोफाइल में आप
जाके इसको डाल दीजिए वहां आपकी कन्फेशन हो
जाएगी या सिंगल टाइम के लिए आप इसको
टेंपरली भी आप इसको यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक
है तो कैसे करना है मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं यहां पे ये वाला एईपी की मैं पहले डाल
देता हूं उसके बाद यह कमांड मैं यहां से
कॉपी कर लेता हूं यहां पे कॉपी किया हमने
अब हम चलते हैं काली में यहां
पे अब हम यहां पे क्या कर देते हैं
एक्सपोर्ट केस एपीआई की एंड यहां पे हम
एपीआई की डाल देते हैं करंट सेशन में आपका
यह काम कर जाएगा अगर आप इसको हमेशा के लिए
काम में लेना चाहते हैं तो आप इसको आपको
इसको जेएसए प्रोफाइल में आपने डालनी
पड़ेगी तो फिलहाल के लिए मैं उसमें डाल
अभी तो नहीं रहा बट यहां पे करेंटली यहां
पे टेंपरली मैं मैंने एी की यहां डाला
एंटर कर दिया अब मैं यहां पे के h
tesla.svs
की लिस्ट है वो प्रोवाइड कर देनी चाहिए तो
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे सब डोमस की लिस्ट
प्रोवाइड कर दी गई है कितनी भाई हुई है तो
h o h o एंड यहां
tesla.svs ने कितने सब डोमेंस 661 इसने भी
वही सब डोमेंस लगभग फाइंड किए हैं जो
हमारे स्टार्टिंग में फाइंड हुए थे बिना
एपीआई की वाली चीज से तो यहां पे 661 यहां
पे टेस्ला के आपके सब डोमस निकले हैं तो
आप केस से भी इस तरीके से फाइंड कर सकते
हैं चलिए अब ये तो आपके सब डोमेन फाइंड
करने का सिस्टम सिस्टम हो गया सब डोमेन
फाइंड मान लो मेरे पास एक सब डोमेन की
लिस्ट क्या आई है
tesla.svs ठीक है चलिए अब मुझे क्या करना
है गाइस हमने यहां पे क्या देखा था
लेट लेट्स सी हमने सीआरटी एसएस से देखा
हमने एमस का देखा हमने सब फाइंडर एफएफ
यूएफ का भी हमने मैंने बोला था एफएफ यूएफ
भी यूज़ कर लेंगे अभी हम कर लेंगे देखेंगे
शॉर्ट एयू शॉटिंग कर ली हमने सब लिस्टर सब
लिस्टर को भी देख लेंगे एसटीटीपी एक एंड
एसटीटी प्रोब एंड लास्ट में केस एंड आई
विटनेस तो अब हमें यहां पे क्या करना है
गाइस कि हमें ये निकालना है हमें यह फाइंड
करना है कि जितने सब डोमेंस के लिस्ट है
उस में कितने सारे एक्टिव सब डोमेंस
है या एचटीटीपी सर्वर रन हो रही है उन पे
यानी कि वो एक्टिव है मतलब उन पे हम कुछ
फाइंड कर सकते हैं वी कैन फाइंड समथिंग ऑन
दोज सब डोस ये हमें अब फाइंड करना है अब
ये कैसे करेंगे भाई इसके लिए हम एक टूल
यूज करेंगे एचटीटीपी एकस एंड ये टूल है
बहुत ही शानदार बहुत ही शानदार बहुत ही
जानदार टूल है ये टूल है एटीटीपी एक
गेट
हब इसको ओपन करना
है यहां आएंगे तो यहां आपको लिखा रहेगा
एचटीटीपी एक्स इज अ जस्ट वेट गाइस लेट मी
स्टार्ट अ सेशन एक क्लास है वह स्टार्ट कर
देता हूं
मैं जस्ट वेट
गाइस जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट
ओके जस्ट वेट मैं एक दूसरा सेशन स्टार्ट
कर रहा
हूं
चलिए ओके डन ओके चलिए
[संगीत]
तो ओके सो यहां पे अब एटीटीपी एकस पे
आइएगा तो एटीटीपी एक इज अ फास्ट एंड मल्टी
पर्पस एटीटीपी टूल किट दैट अलाउ रनिंग
मल्टीपल प्रोब्स यूजिंग द रिट्रायबल
एसटीटीपी लाइब्रेरी रिट्रायबल एसटीटीपी
लाइब्रेरी का यूज करता है ये अब यहां पे
क्या कर सकते हैं बस देखते जाइए देखते
जाइए कितना इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है यह कितना
कुछ कर सकते हैं आप आप बेसिकली इसका यूज
करके ठीक है करके यह पता लगा सकते हैं कि
कौन सी वेबसाइट अभी काम कर रही है चल रही
है किस पे कौन सा प्रोटोकॉल यूज हो रहा है
सीडीपी आ सीडीपीएस और बहुत सारी चीजें यू
कैन गो यू कैन डू एक्चुअली ठीक है तो अब
देखो यहां पे इसको इंस्टॉल करने के लिए
क्या करना है यह कमांड चलाना है गो
इंस्टॉल हान बी इस तरीके से यह कमांड आपको
चला देनी है बट काली में भैया आपको यह बाय
डिफॉल्ट इसके रिपोजिटरी में मिलता है काली
में इसके लिए आपको कुछ नहीं करना है क्या
करना है है एट लिस्ट एंड एटीटीपी एक बट
काली में क्या मिलता है टूल किट काली में
क्या मिलता है
सॉरी एटीटीपी एक टूल किट नाम से ये पैकेज
अवेलेबल है एटीटीपी एक टूल किट ये करके
एटीटीपी पे करके एंटर कीजिएगा आपको ये दिख
जाएगा अब इसको इंस्टॉल करना है कैसे एट
इंस्टॉल एटीटीपी एक सॉरी टूल किट यह करना
है और आपका यह एटीटीपी एक जो क्लाइंट है
ये इंस्टॉल होना स्टार्ट हो जाएगा एंड इट
विल गेट इंस्टॉल्ड चलिए चलिए स्टार्ट इसको
इंस्टॉल होने इंस्टॉल हो चुका अब हम एडीपी
एक टूल किट सॉरी वैसे एडीपी एक है बट काली
में य एडीपी एक टूल किट नाम से पैकेज है
हान ए कीजिएगा इसकी पूरी लिस्ट जो है हे
फाइल जो है वो आपकी आ जाएगी जो एटीपी एक
की अवेलेबल है यहां पे अब
देखो चलो यहां पे ही कर लेते हैं एटीटीपी
एक गेट हब एंड यहां से ही ओपन कर लेते हैं
यह वाली यह रही इसको थोड़ा सा मैं जूम इन
कर देता हूं ताकि आपको ज्यादा अच्छे सेख
पेज चलिए यह रही नीचे आते हैं अब यहां पर
इसको यूज करना है कैसे करना है मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं चलिए देखिए सिंपल कैट कमांड के
साथ टी एक्सटी फाइल सब डोमेन की पास करनी
है और यहां एसटीटीपी एक्स लगा देना है ट्स
ऑल चलिए सबसे पहला सबसे सिंपल हमारा यूज
केस यही है क्या है कैट लगाना है टेस्ला
कौन सा है भैया टेस्ला यूनिक यिक
डटी इस पे पास क्या करना है इसपे पास क्या
करना है आपकी एसटीटीपी एक टूल किट यह पास
कर देना है बस
दैट्ची बात है लिस्ट चलिए अब इसको क्या
करते हैं मैं इसको क्या कर देता हूं सिंपल
इसको एक फाइल में डाल देता हूं फाइल का
नाम डाल देते हैं टेस्ला फाइनल ड
txxx.com
लाइव सेशन जूम पर कुछ नहीं होता अभी तो
अभी तो फिलहाल बग बाउंट यहां पर फ्री में
चल रही है आपकी तो यह एक फाइल बनाएगा याद
रखिएगा ला फाल एकटी एंड आपको अगर फाइल
देखनी है लाइव देखनी है तो आप लाइव देखिए
ला फल कहां गईला फल ये रही यह फाइल बन रही
है इस फाइल में एंट्री हो रही होगी अभी
लाइव हो रही होगी देखो यहां
पे एक mail.com है लास्ट एंट्री देखते
हैं हो रही है या हो गई
है तो ये आपको बता देता है कौन से
एसटीटीपी कौन सा एसटीटीपी वेब सर्वर रन हो
रहा है प्रोटोकॉल यूज हो रहा है कहां पे
एचटीटीपीएस वाला प्रोटोकॉल यूज हो रहा है
कौन से लाइक डोमेन पे सब डोमेन पे ये सब
कुछ दे देता है तो हो गया शायद हो गया
क्या अच्छा हो गया क्या चलिए हो गया तो
यहां पे आ गई अब हम देख लेते हैं कितने
उसमें सब डोमेन है भैया तो कैट टेस्ला फइल
टीड सफल हमने किया था लगभग कितने पे चार
1600 पे किया था ना लगभग 1600 पे उसमें से
चार 438 सब डोमस इसने फाइंड किए हैं जिस
पर वेब सर्वर रन हो रहा है या प्रोटोकॉल ऑ
एसटीटीपी हो एचटीटीपीएस हो नो मैटर व्ट तो
ये आपको समझ में आ गया कितना इंटरेस्टिंग
है आपने लाइव डोमेंस को फाइंड कर लिया यू
गॉट लाइव डोमेंस
राइट यस यस यस वी वी आर चेकिंग इट्स लाइव
और नॉट हाउ मेनी सब डोमेंस आर लाइव और हाउ
मेनी सब डोमेंस आर डेड मतलब लाइव सब
डोमेंस कितने हमने इससे यह पता किया
मजेदार है कि नहीं है यह बताइए मुझे
मजेदार है कि की नहीं
है हे होम डायरेक्टरी में एमएस नहीं मिल
रहा है कोई बात नहीं होम में आ जाइए यहां
व्यू पे जाइए एंड यहां पे शो हिडन फाइल्स
पे क्लिक कीजिए तब आपको ये
कॉन्फिन में सॉरी यहां पे मिल चुके हैं अब
इस एटीटीपी एक टूल किट का यही काम नहीं है
इसका और बहुत काम है भाई इसमें बहुत सारे
फीचर है चलो देखते हैं कौन-कौन से फीचर है
मैं दिखाता हूं चलिए अब यहां पे अगर आपको
प्रोब करना है जैसे प्रोब वाली चीज देखनी
है ना कि प्रोब करके तो यह वाला कमांड आप
चला सकते हो एटीटीपी हाइन लिस्ट एंड फिर
सब डोमेन की लिस्ट और फिर प्रोब आप लगा
सकते हो तो चलिए यह वाला कमांड भी हम चला
के देख लेते हैं कौन सा कमांड चलाएंगे एक
बार देखने में क्या जाता है एटीटीपी एकस
टूल किट हमने दे दिया हाइन लिस्ट लिस्ट दे
दी अब यहां पर क्या करना है हमें
टेस्ला यूनिक वाला ही क डाल देते हैं उसके
बाद हाइन साइलेंट डाल देंगे और हाइन प्रोब
ये वाला कमांड हमने यहां पे डाल दिया हाइन
प्रोब एंड हाइफ साइलेंट अब हमें ये क्या
दिखाएगा देखो मैं एंटर करता हूं देखो यहां
पे ये दिखाएगा कि कौन-कौन से डोमेन को ये
प्रोब कर पा रहा है कौन-कौन से डोमेन को
ये प्रूव नहीं कर पा रहा है तो यहां पे
सक्सेस फेल्ड सक्सेस फेल्ड ये दिखा रहा है
थोड़ा हैकर वाली फीलिंग आ रही है आपको वो
आपको यहां दिखाएगा कि कौन-कौन से इसको को
ये प्रोब कर पाया किस-किस को नहीं प्रोव
कर पाया प्रोव का मतलब किस-किस डोमेन तक
यह पहुंच पाया इसकी रिक्वेस्ट पहुंच पाई
अगर जिसकी पहुंच पाई यानी वह काम कर रही
है रेस्पों कर रही है तो यहां सक्सेस है
नहीं पहुंच पाई रेस्प नहीं कर रही है वो
अनसक्सेसफुल है सिंपल सा फंडा है ठीक है
यह तो आपको सब कुछ समझ में आ गया
होगा अब देखिए यहां पर मैं इसमें देखता
हूं डब्लू सी हाइ फनल देखते हैं कितने यह
कितने लाइक हमें लिस्ट देता है कितने सब
डोमेंस की लिस्ट देता है आपको मैं एक चीज
दिखाता
हूं
लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी वर्ड काउंट वी आर
गेटिंग लेट्स वेट फॉर द रिजल्ट डब्लू स
हाइ फनल का कि कितने वर्ड काउंट आपको यहां
पर मिलते
हैं इसने अच्छा इसने सबको वो किया ना सबको
कर दिया मतलब इसने सबको काउंट कर लिया है
कि जो फेल्ड है या जो सक्सेस है व्हाट एवर
सबको इसने काउंट कर दिया है इसलिए यहां पे
यहां पे 1011 जो जो टोटल आपके आ रहे हैं
ये 1011 आ रहे है लेकिन लेकिन 1011 जो आ
रहे हैं आपके भैया ये कौन से सब डोमेन है
101 जो यूनिक सब डोमस आपके निकल के आए थे
बेसिकली 101 वाला वही वाला सब डोमस है जो
कि आपको यहां पे मिल रहा है एचटीटीपी
प्रोव करने के बाद तो ये आपको यहां पे मिल
गई 101 बट अब मुझे मुझे एक और इसका यूज
केस करना है कैसे करना है मुझे मान लो
यहां पे नीचे आना है सीआईडीआर इनपुट आप
इसमें सीआईडीआर इनपुट भी डाल दे सकते हो
जैसे हमें सीआईडीआर मिले थे ना तो
सीआईडीआर दे दोगे सारी आईपी एड्रेस दे
देगा ये भी है एसएन नंबर इनपुट दे सकते हो
एएसएन नंबर डाला उससे रिलेटेड जितने भी
आपकी आईपीस है वो आपको प्रोवाइड कर देगा
इसको आप दूसरे टूल के साथ भी यूज कर सकते
हो सबसे बड़ी बात ये है अब ये टूल के साथ
भैया यूज करने वाला सीन बहुत शानदार है
इसको कैसे यूज करना है टूल के साथ कैसे
यूज करेंगे यह आपको यहां पे दिख जाएगा ये
देखो एक तो पहले एटीटीपी एक कमांड आपको दे
देना है ये आप दे दोगे उसके बाद हाइफ हाइ
फन टाइटल टेक डिटेक्ट स्टेटस कोड्स तो ये
आपको सारे सब डोमस के स्टेटस कोड दिखाएगा
टेक्नोलॉजी कौन सी यूज़ हो रही है दिखाएगा
टाइटल क्या है उस पर्टिकुलर वेब पेज का वो
दिखाएगा सब आपको यहां पे दिखाएगा तो आप
इसको सब फाइंडर के साथ भी यूज कर सकते हो
ये भी चीज है सम फाइंडर के साथ आल्सो यू
कैन यूज दिस टूल दैट इज नोन एज एटीटीपी एक
फिलहाल के लिए हमें इसको सिंपल यूज करना
है और तो कुछ करना नहीं है एस एंड
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग और ये सब अभी करना नहीं है
इसके साथ-साथ आप इसके साथ इसी टूल से
एटीटीपी एक से आप स्क्रीनशॉट भी ले सकते
हैं एक एक पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट का
स्क्रीनशॉट लेना हो एक पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन
के लिस्ट का स्क्रीनशॉट लेना हो या ट
व्हाट एवर सॉरी आप स्क्रीनशॉट भी ले सकते
हो दिस इज आल्सो कैन बी डन विद दिस टूल
ठीक है तो ये बहुत ही शानदार टूल है
एटीटीपी एक इससे आप लाइव प्रूप कर सकते हो
और हमने जब प्रूव किया तो हमारे पास लाइव
सब डोमेंस कितने मिले हैं भैया कौन से
मिले हैं ये वाले
tesla.svs स्क्रीनशॉटिंग हम करेंगे उसके
बाद हम डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स और भी बहुत
सारी चीजें करेंगे बट फिलहाल आज के सेशन
में स्क्रीनशॉटिंग वाला काम हम जरूर
करेंगे ठीक है स्क्रीनशॉटिंग के लिए बहुत
सारे टूल्स आते हैं आई विटनेस करके टूल है
वेब स्क्रीनशॉट है सीटीपी स्क्रीनशॉट है
बहुत सारे टूल्स आते हैं बट हम यहां पे
सबसे ज्यादा पॉपुलर टूल यूज करेंगे आई
विटनेस जो कि काली रिपोजिटरी में ऑलरेडी
है काली रिपोजिटरी के अंदर वाली टूल यूज
करो मजे आते रहेंगे तुम्हें आई
विटनेस
विटनेस करोगे लिस्टेड है ऑलरेडी मेरा तो
इंस्टॉल्ड है आप चाहो तो इंस्टॉल कर लीजिए
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यहां पे एप्ट इंस्टॉल
कमांड चला लीजिए एप्ट इंस्टॉल आई विटनेस
एंड दैट
इट इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा अब इसको यूज़ कैसे
करना है भाई आई विटनेस को तो चलिए यहां पे
इसकी भी रिपोजिटरी को देख लेते हैं आई
विटनेस गिट हब यहां चलते
हैं सॉरी
यहां पे आ जाते हैं यहां जब नीचे आएंगे तो
यहां पे आपको
linux.com है उसके बाद यहां पे आप फर्द जो
कमांड्स है वो डाल दीजिए जैसे कि यहां पे
h f
url.py न एन वेब लगाया हुआ है आप ना लगाना
चाहो ना लगाओ प्रॉक्सी डालना चाहते हो
प्रॉक्सी डा भैया आपको अगर प्रॉक्सी लगानी
है आप प्रॉक्सी लगा दो आपको अगर यहां पर
टाइम आउट वगैरह लगाना है आप टाइम आउट वगर
लगा दो थोड़े से बच जाओगे और तो कुछ नहीं
करोगे बस सिंपल सा तो अब हमारे पास जो
फाइनल लिस्ट है सब डोमेन की उसके
स्क्रीनशॉट लेंगे कौन सा है टेस्ला
सॉरी टेस्ला फाइनल डटी एकटी इसको हम
स्क्रीनशॉट करने वाले चलिए इन सबको डिलीट
मारते इस पर आ जाते तो अब हम आते हैं य प
आई विटनेस पे हाइन एच हमें नहीं आती है
भाई कैसे यूज करना है तो हम इसको देखेंगे
ना इसकी हे फाइल को क्या करेंगे आई विटनेस
के बाद हमें लगाना है यहां पर हान एफ
कंटेनिंग यूआरएल टू कैप्चर फाइल नेम दे
देनी है तो चलिए हान एफ लगा देते हैं आई
विटनेस हान f यूआरएल क्या है टेस्ला फाइनल
t एकटी यह हमने यूआरएल दे दिया कि लिस्ट
दे दी मतलब फाइल की उसके बाद हमें क्या
करना
है उसके बाद हमें यहां पे और कुछ तो करना
नहीं
है डायरेक्टरी रिपोर्ट हां पे आपको
रिपोर्ट चाहिए उसकी डायरेक्टरी अगर आप
मेंशन करना चाहते हैं कर दीजिए अदर वाइज
कोई बात नहीं कोई टेंशन नहीं है आपकी सेम
करंट डायरेक्टरी में हो जाएगी ये डेस्कटॉप
पे ही ठीक है एंड बाकी कुछ है नहीं यहां
प्रॉक्सी आईपीएफ लगा सकते हैं वेब
प्रॉक्सी टू गो थ्रू प्रॉक्सी आईपी लगाना
चाहते हैं लगा सकते हैं प्रॉक्सी पोर्ट
लगा सकते हैं ये सब चीजें कर सकते हैं आप
सॉक्स फाइ वगैरह यूज कर सकते हैं प्रॉक्सी
वगैरह अगर आप चाहे तो कर सकते हैं ठीक है
या आप रिजॉल्वर यूज कर सकते हैं डीएनएस
रिजॉल्वर्स होते हैं उनकी लिस्ट आप ले
सकते हैं और रिजॉल्वर्स भी यूज कर सकते
हैं हाइफान हाफ रिजॉल्व लगा के फाइल को
मेंशन करके चलिए तो अब यहां पे हो चुका
सारा काम अब यहां पे क्या करते हैं गाइस
कि
कि हो गया इतना इतना ही करके कर देते हैं
स्क्रीनशॉट ले लेते हैं क्या दिक्कत है
यहां पे अ हान वेब स्क्रीनशॉट लेना है तो
हान f वेब लगा दीजिए हान एफन वेब बस हो
गया
[संगीत]
दैट्ची एंड लेट्स वेट अब 438 होस्ट यहां
पे दे रखा है 438 होस्ट को यह स्क्रीनशॉट
लेने की कोशिश करेगा एंड इट्स स्टार्टेड
अटेम्प्टिंग टू स्क्रीनशॉट अब यहां पे हिट
टाइम आउट लिमिट है यहां पे भैया अब देखो
यहां पे टाइम आउट लिमिट यहां पे हिट हो जा
रहा है हम यहां पे टाइम आउट लिमिट को
थोड़ा इंक्रीज डिक्रीज कर सकते हैं जैसे
यहां पे ना देखो टाइम आउट का होगा यहां पे
ये टाइम आउट डिफॉल्ट सेवन है तो टाइम आउट
को थोड़ा सा हम बढ़ा देते हैं कंट्रोल सी
कर देता हूं मैं इसको क्लियर कर देता हूं
मैं इसको एंड यहां पे ऑलरेडी बन गई होगी
शायद आई विटनेस की यह रही ये एक फोल्डर
बनी है ना इसी के अंदर स्क्रीनशॉट आएगी
आपकी मैं क्या कर देता हूं इस फोल्डर को
भैया यहां पर डिलीट कर देता हूं अभी
फिलहाल के लिए मैं ना टाइम आउट को थोड़ा
बढ़ा देता हूं टाइम आउट बहुत कम
था सो कमांड में यहां पे यहां पर हमने
यहां पर टाइम आउट देना है हाइ फन हाइ फन
टाइम आउट इसको कर देते हैं हाइन हाइ फन
टाइम आउट 120 सेकंड का कर देते हैं
मैक्सिमम टाइम आउट थ्रेड जो है वो देख
लेते हैं थ्रेड कितना है
इनका नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड टू यूज वाइल यूजिंग
फाइल बेस्ड इनपुट नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स तो
थ्रेड को हम 300 कर दे या थ्रेड रहने देते
हैं डिफॉल्ट देखते हैं क्या होता है ठीक
है तो एंटर अब करते हैं एंटर टाइम आउट
हमने बढ़ा दिया है तो थोड़ा सा हमें जो है
वो इजली जो है स्क्रीनशॉट्स मिलने स्टार्ट
हो जाने चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से टाइम आउट
वाला सीन नहीं आना चाहिए जैसे पहले आ रहा
था तो अभी अटेंप्ट कर रहा है चलिए बढ़िया
बात है दूसरे भी अटेंप्ट कर रहा है ये भी
अच्छी बात है देखा टाइम आउट को हमने
बढ़ाया तो क्योंकि 7 सेकंड का बस टाइम आउट
था जैसे ही 7 सेकंड हो रहा था और अगर 7
सेकंड के अंदर नहीं नहीं ले पा रहा था ये
स्क्रीनशॉट तो ये टाइम आउट कर दे रहा था
फिर नेक्स्ट होस्ट पे चला जा रहा था तो
ऐसा नहीं चाहिए ना भाई हमें चाहिए कि
प्रॉपर टाइम दो भाई और तब ट्राई करो देखो
ये स्क्रीनशॉट अटेंप्ट कर रहा है भैया ये
यहां पे और ये कर रहा है ये अटेंप्ट बहुत
बढ़िया अटेंप्ट कर रहा है चलिए यहां पे
फोल्डर में चलते हैं देखते हैं
स्क्रीनशॉट्स आ रहे हैं कि नहीं आ रहे हैं
भाई अरे खुल जा सिम सिम क्या हुआ खुल गया
क्या खुल गया ये
स्क्रीन खोल देते हैं स्क्रीन देखो भैया
अभी कितने हैं इसमें नाइन फाइल्स हैं 10
फाइल्स देखो लाइव दिखेगा तुम्हें
स्क्रीनशॉट्स इसमें कैप्चर होते हुए लाइव
ऐसी लाइव चीज देखी है क्या कहीं भाई लाइव
दे रहे हैं लाइव स्क्रीनशॉटिंग हो रही है
देखो लाइव फोल्डर फाइल्स बन रहे हैं यहां
पे
तुम्हारे थैंक्स ऋषिकेश ठाकरे थैंक
यू आई एम कंप्लीट माय डे थर्ड वेरी गुड
बहुत
बढ़िया क्या करेंगे स्क्रीनशॉट का बहुत
अच्छा क्वेश्चन है बताऊंगा क्या करेंगे
स्क्रीनशॉट का बहुत ज्यादा बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंस है आपके स्क्रीनशॉट का भाई
स्क्रीनशॉट को देख के तुम पता लगाओगे कि
उस पर्टिकुलर पेज पे क्या आ रही है उस
पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन पे वहां पे कोई
डायरेक्टरी लिस्टिंग हो रही है वहां पे
कोई पर्टिकुलर लॉगिन पैनल है वहां पे कोई
सेंसिटिव लॉगइन पैनल है कोई इंफॉर्मेशन
लीकेज हो रहा है कोई ऐसा पैनल है जहां पे
आप जाके आप इनपुट वाली वने एबिलिटीज अ
फाइंड करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो एक्सेसेस
के लिए ट्राई कर सकते हो एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन के लिए ट्राई कर सकते हो कमांड
इंजेक्शन मतलब हर चीज ट्राई कर सकते हो ये
सारी चीजों के लिए चाहिए स्क्रीनशॉट भाई
एंड इसी के लिए हमें एनालाइज करने के लिए
समझ में आया गॉट
इट धन्यवाद धन्यवाद चलिए तो ये
स्क्रीनशॉट्स आ रही है अ कितने हो गए भाई
इसके 30 इसने कंप्लीट किए हैं आउट ऑफ 438
सर्विसेस थोड़ा धीरे हो रहा है ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं आप थ्रेड को बढ़ा सकते हो इसमें
जो हाइन थ्रेड ऑप्शन दिया हुआ है ना देखो
यहां पे ये थ्रेड बढ़ा दोगे तो थोड़ी
स्पीड बढ़ जाएगी जैसे कहां गया थ्रेड कहां
गया थ्रेड कहां गया थ्रेड कहां गया थ्रेड
थ्रेड ये रहा थ्रेड तो ये थ्रेड आप बढ़ा
दोगे तो स्क्रीनशॉट जो स्पीड है थोड़ी बढ़
जाएगी और यहां पे ये डिले ऑफ सेकंड्स है
डिले बिटवीन द ओपनिंग ऑफ द नेविगेटर एंड
टेकिंग द स्क्रीनशॉट डिले भी बढ़ा दोगे तो
ब्लॉक होने के चांसेस थोड़े कम हो जाएंगे
यह भी चीज है ठीक है तो हमने फिलहाल टाइम
आउट बढ़ा के ही सारा काम कर लिया है तो
हमें फिलहाल और ज्यादा कुछ जरूरत नहीं है
किसी चीज की बाकी तो अपना काम हो ही रहा
है भाई यह देखिए इतने सारे स्क्रीनशॉट
यहां पे आते जा रहे हैं आते जा रहे हैं
आते जा रहे हैं अब इन स्क्रीनशॉट्स को आप
एकएक करके ओपन करके भैया देख सकते हो कि
इन स्क्रीनशॉट्स में क्या-क्या है उस पेज
पर पर्टिकुलर क्या लिस्टेड है क्या है डबल
क्लिक करो यह ओपन होगा होगा
क्या क्या बात है पूरी लिस्ट आ गई यह देखो
इस वाले सब डोमेन प एक लॉगिन पैनल का
स्क्रीनशॉट है भैया अच्छी बात है दूसरे
वाले पर चलिए कुछ भी नहीं है तीसरे वाले प
चलिए ये देखिए स सर्विस अवेलेबल यह आ रहा
है द सर्वर टेंपली अनेबल टू प्रोवाइड यू द
सर्विस बढ़िया यह ऐसे आ रहा है एक वाले प
एक जो सब डोमेन है उस पर यह है क्या है
यह ओके यह यहां पर ऊपर में सब डोमेन का
नाम है एक अमाई ड एपीआई गेटवे सब डोमेन का
जो यूआरएल है वो भी दिया हुआ
है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है चलिए आते हैं इस
पे या तो इस पर आते हैं इस पर कुछ नहीं
सर्विस अन अवेलेबल इस पर आते हैं सर्विस
अन अवेलेबल सर्विस अन अवेलेबल सर्विस अन
अवेलेबल सर्विस अन अवेलेबल कुछ खास यहां
पे है नहीं कुछ खास यहां पे है नहीं कुछ
खास यहां पे है
नहीं अ
नॉट नॉट मच कुछ खास यहां पे है नहीं यहां
पे अभी कुछ खास यहां पे कुछ खास तो यहां
पे अभी है नहीं अभी बहुत सारी
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग तो अभी बाकी है यार अभी तो
बहुत सारे स्क्रीनशॉट्स होने बाकी हैं
उसमें आपको शायद कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग मिल जाए
या कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग आपको दिख जाए देन दैट
कैन बी अ केस टू प्रोसीड फर्द आप आगे फिर
बढ़ सकते हैं और आगे उसमें वनबिल फाइंड
करने के लिए ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं देखो
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग का क्या मतलब है आपको मैं
आपको सीधा-सीधा बता देता हूं ठीक
है आई थॉट वी नीड टू विजिट एवरी सब डोमेन
दिस टूल इज ऑसम नहीं आपको विजिट नहीं करना
आपको बस इसके स्क्रीनशॉट ले लेके और देखनी
है एकएक करके एंड यू विल गेट टू नो ऑल द
डिटेल्स बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मिलती है
भाई ये तो बहुत छोटा सा लिस्ट है सब डोमेन
का जब तुम क्लाउड यूज कर रहे होंगे ना
क्लाउड में मशीन क्लाउड में u12 या काली
को यूज कर रहे होंग हंटिंग के लिए या
वीपीएस वगैरह कोई यूज कर रहे होंग तो
उसमें इतनी फास्ट होगी ये प्रोसेस कि 2
मिनट में हो जाएगा एक मिनट में सारे
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग हो गई 1 मिनट में आपकी
न्यूमरेशन हो गई और बहुत अच्छे से आपकी
सारी चीजें होने वाली है बहुत फास्ट होती
है तो वहां तुम्हें इतना वो वेट नहीं करना
पड़ेगा और तब तुम एनालाइज करोगे नाना वहां
पे लाखों लाखों सब डोमेन को एनालाइज करोगे
यहां मतलब
करते हैं आएंगे भाई आएंगे सब डोमन टेकओवर
पे भी आएंगे टेंशन नहीं लेने
का ठीक
है हां जी बिल्कुल सही है बार-बार आपको सब
डोमन पे देखने की जरूरत नहीं है जाने की
जरूरत नहीं है तो हमने आज अभी क्या देखा
सीआरटीएस का आपने आपको देखा आपने देखा यूज
करके एमएस को आपने यूज करना सीखा कैसे
यूज़ करना है एमएस को सब फाइंडर एफएफ यूएफ
एफएफ यूएफ हां जी हां जी तो हमने एफएफ
यूएफ अभी तक नहीं देखा है एंड एफएफ यूएफ
जो है यह वाइ ड कार्ड एक तरीका है सब
डोमेन को ब्रूट फोर्स करने के लिए याद
रखिएगा सब डोमेन को ब्रूट फोर्स करने के
लिए आप एफएफ यूएफ का भी यूज कर सकते हैं
चलिए यह भी मैं आपको बता ही देता हूं यह
भी बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है इसको अटेम्प्ट
स्क्रीनशॉट होने देते हैं कोई टेंशन नहीं
है इसने 60 स्क्रीनशॉट लिए है आप चाहे तो
इस पर बंद कर दीजिए या इसको चलते रहने
दीजिए व आपकी मर्जी है बट मैं क्या करता
हूं मैं बंद कर देता हूं इतनी ज्यादा क्या
टाइम लेना स्क्रीनशॉट को मैंने यहां पर
बंद कर दिया एंड चलिए यह वाला फोल्डर देख
लेते हैं स्क्रीनशॉट वाली स्क्रीन वाली
फोल्डर इतने सारे स्क्रीनशॉट इतने सारे
हमारे पास आ गए हैं मोस्टली इसमें सेम
रिजल्ट्स ही देखने को मिल रहे हैं बट ठीक
है आप इसको एनालाइज कर सकते हैं फर्द डबल
क्लिक कीजिए एंड आपको सारी स्क्रीनशॉट मिल
जाएगी आप नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट एरो की
प्रेस कीजिए और अपनी जो भी आपका यह फाइल
मैनेजर है उसमें आपको यह दिखता चला जाएगा
इसके अलावा देखो अभी एक चीज और दिखाता
हूं क्लोज कर दो
भाई क्या हो रहा है
ये ओके नथिंग इज वर्किंग क्या हैंग कर गया
क्या यार ऐसे हैंग कर
गया
ओके एक काम करते इसको मिनिमाइज करते हैं ए
यहां से टर्मिनल ओपन होगा क्या ओके नथिंग
इ
ओपनिंग वर्चुल म की एक अलग ही खूबी है
ज्यादा दिक्कत दे रीस्टार्ट मार दो यह
वर्चुअल मशीन की खूबी
है जी हां एफएफ यूएफ बहुत ही धांसू टूल है
चलिए एफएफ यूएफ पे चलते हैं इसका थोड़ा
समझ लेते हैं क्या है देखिए एफएफ यूएफ टूल
जो है ना फजिंग के लिए यूज में आता है
आपको तो पता ही होगा लेकिन इसका और भी
बहुत सारे यूज है फज करके आप सब डोमस भी
न्यूमेट कर सकते हैं एंड इसके लिए आपको एक
वड लिस्ट चाहिए भाई वर्ड लिस्ट अब वर्ड
लिस्ट तुम बहुत सारे अवेलेबल है भाई तुम
निकाल सकते हो बट यहां देखो सब डोमेन वर्ड
लिस्ट सेक लिस्ट सेक लिस्ट के अंदर भी
आपको बहुत सारे सब डोमेन की वर्ड लिस्ट
मिल जाएगी चलिए सेक लिस्ट नाम का एक
डायरेक्टरी रिपोजिटरी है आपकी अ यहां पे
सेक लिस्ट ना ये रिपोजिटरी है इसमें आप
आएंगे तो यहां पे आप डीएनएस वाले को
एक्सपेंड करेंगे डीएनएस वाले को जैसे चलिए
ये जैसे मैं आपको ऐसे दिखा देता हूं सेक
लिस्ट में है यहां पे अब यहां पे आ जाइए
अ फजिंग में आ जाइए फजिंग में आ जाइए एंड
यहां पर आ जाइए फजिंग के
अंदर ओके डिस्कवरी में आ जाते हैं हां
डिस्कवरी में आ जाइए इसको डीएनएस को
एक्सपेंड कीजिए डीएनएस को एक्सपेंड करेंगे
तो यहां पे आपको नीचे आएंगे तो यहां पे
आपको दिखेंगे दिखेंगे शुभ सब डोमेन सब
डोमेन स्पैनिश सब डोमेन टॉप 1 मिलियन सब
डोमेन टॉप 1 मिलियन ये सारे सब डोमस की एक
वर्ड फाइल वर्ड लिस्ट आ जाएगी आपको इन
वर्ड लिस्ट का यूज आप कर सकते हो एंड आप
एफएफ यूएफ के अंदर इसको यूज करके देख सकते
हो इसके अलावा एक और वर्ड लिस्ट
है एन0 के ओवी ओ गिट हब इस पे आ जाइए आप
इनके गिट हब प्रोफाइल पे नो कोवो व्हाट
एवर सॉरी फॉर मिस प्रोनंसिएशन रिपोजिटरी
पे आ जाते हैं एंड इनका एक रिपोजिटरी है अ
सब डोमेन का वयर इट इज सब फाइंडर सब
फाइंडर
सब ये भी काफी अच्छा है ऑसम सब डोमेन
न्यूमरेशन ये ये ये मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं पहले पहले सब डोमेन प आ जाते
हैं ये नोको वो सब डोमेंस इस पर आ
जाइएगा यहां पे भी आपको वड लिस्ट मिल
जाएगी सब डोमस के लिए आप इनको भी यूज कर
सकते हैं लार्ज मीडियम जो भी स्मॉल व्हाट
एवर दिस आर आप यूज कर सकते हैं और इनका एक
यहां पे सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन का ऑसम यहां
पे सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन है बट यहां पे
इन्होंने कुछ शायद हटा दिया है या नहीं है
चलिए हटा दीजिए गोली वाली तो ये वर्डलिस्ट
मिल गई अब हम एफएफ यूएफ के अंदर कैसे यूज़
करेंगे पहले ये देख लेते हैं चलो एफएफ
यूएफ में आ गए हम यहां पे यहां पे आप आ गए
अब यहां पे नीचे आओ नीचे आओ नीचे आओ नीचे
आओ यहां पे कंटेंट डिस्कवरी है वी होस्ट
डिस्कवरी है पैरामीटर फजिंग है देखो यहां
पे अब नीचे आ जाते हैं और यहां पे सर्च कर
लेते हैं सब डोमेन का कुछ सिस्टम है नहीं
है कोई बात नहीं अ एफ य जड जड डॉट इसका भी
सिस्टम नहीं है अब चलिए मैं यहां पे एक
चीज दिखाता हूं पैरामीटर फजिंग में चलते
हैं यहां पे एंड जब यहां पे तुम पैरामीटर
फजिंग पे आ जाओगे भैया तो कोई पैरामीटर को
फज करना हो ना तो यहां पे लास्ट में फज इज
इक्वल टू पैरामीटर जो भी पैरामीटर का है
वोह आप तुम डाल के पैरामीटर को फर्ज कर
सकते हो एक तो यह तरीका हो जाता है ठीक है
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अब यहां पे आते हैं
नीचे एंड ऊपर चलते हैं यहां पे एक और चीज
करते हैं वी होस्ट डिस्कवरी पे आ जाते हैं
एंड यू कैन सी यहां पे कि वी होस्ट
डिस्कवरी के लिए आप इसको यूज कैसे कर सकते
हो ऐसे एफएफ यूएफ तो है ही यहां पे
वर्डलिस्ट का आप यहां पे पाथ दे दीजिए
उसके बाद हान य और टारगेट जो है ना टारगेट
यहां पर इस तरीके से आप इसको फज कर सकते
हो यहां पर टारगेट होस्ट इक्वल टू फज ऐसे
करके या फिर तुम टारगेट को यूआरएल में फज
डाल के और यह काम कर सकते हो कैसे कर सकते
हो मैं आपको बताता हूं एफफ यूएफ का यूज
केस यहां पर हमारा लॉग इन कर लेते
हैं चलिए हमने लगन य पर कर
लिया हमें एक वड लिस्ट चाहिए याद रखिएगा
वड लिस्ट और भी जगह अवेलेबल है बहुत
सारे तो वर्डलिस्ट कहां पर अवेलेबल है और
जगह भाई हमारे यूएसआर के अंदर में यूएसआर
के अंदर में शेयर के अंदर में शेयर के
अंदर में आएंगे तो यहां वर्ड लिस्ट सर्च
कीजिए वर्ड लिस्ट इसमें आ
जाइए एंड यहां पर आपको दिख जाएगा एमस तो
दिख रहा है एमस के अंदर भी आपको दिख जाएगा
डब्लू फज इसके अंदर आ जाइए इसके अंदर भी
आपको बहुत सारे वर्डलिस्ट जो है वह मिल
जाएंगे ये जनरल वाले हैं और भी बहुत सारे
हैं वो भी मिल जाएंगे अदर्स में आएंगे
आपको अदर्स में यहां पर मिल जाएगा ठीक है
फिलहाल के लिए आप एमएस पे आएंगे एमएस में
भी आपको बहुत सारे मिल जाएंगे यहां पे आप
देख सकते हैं बिट कर्क सब डोमेन टॉप 100k
यह देखा सब डोमेन यहां पे सब डोमेन टॉप 1
मिलियन सब डोम डॉट लिस्ट ये सारे आपको
यहां पे मिल जाएंगे ठीक है तो सब डोमस
वाली वर्ड लिस्ट यहां पे मिल जाएगी तो यह
भी आप कर लिया और ऊपर से आप इसको भी
डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं यह जो फाइल है आपकी
यह वाली लेस्ट सब डोमेन वाली तो यह वाली
भी आप ले सकते हैं तो जैसे मान लो मैं
मीडियम वाली ले लेता हूं ए को मम वाली है
इसको मैं ले लेता हूं यहां से
हां इसको मैं यहां से ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड
यहां से ही इसको हम क्या कर लेते हैं
डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं काली में ही डाउनलोड
कर लेते
हैं तो चलिए हमने यहां पर किया हमने किया
एंटर और होप फुली इट विल
ओपन चलिए यह ओपन हो चुका अब इसको हमें
सिंपली क्या करना है भैया नॉट
फाउंड क्या आ रहा है क्लिक किया हमने
मीडियम ड इसको क्लिक किया ये आ गया य
पे अरे यार हट जाओ भाई ये क्या आ रहा है
इसको बैक करो यहां हमने डाउनलोड प क्लिक
किया एंड इट विल स्टार्ट डाउनलोडिंग ये
डाउनलोड हो गई 7 एबी की फाइल है यार बहुत
बड़ी फाइल है ये बहुत बड़ी फाइल है तो ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं हम इसको यूज कर लेंगे
फिलहाल के लिए इसको मैं क्या कर लेता हूं
अ
डेस्कटॉप पे ही डाल देता हूं फिलहाल के
लिए डेस्कटॉप पे हम डाल देते हैं अब हम
डब्लू सॉरी अब हम एफएफ यूएफ का यूज करने
वाले हैं तो एफएफ यूएफ का यूज कैसे करेंगे
देखिए यहां प एफ एफ यू एफ हमने कर दिया
यहां पे अब हम यहां पे क्या करेंगे हाइन
यू डालेंगे और यहां पे हम यूआरएल मेंशन
करेंगे हाइन यू देके हम यहां पे यूआरएल
मेंशन करेंगे तो जहां पे हमें हंट करना है
जो सब लोग देख रहे हो ना भाई बहुत कम लोग
हो गए क्या बात है इतने कम लोग कैसे हो गए
भाई वई सो लेस पीपल लेट हो गया बहुत लेट
हो गया क्या हार मान
गए कोई बात नहीं चलिए तो हमने यहां पे कर
लिया अब हम यहां पे यूआरएल देंगे तो हान h
देख लीजिएगा पहले हेल्प फाइल के लिए कैसे
आपको यहां पे देना होता है बेसिकली यूआरएल
वगैरह या जो भी है कैसे देना है तो आपको
यहां पे एग्जांपल्स यहां पे दिख रहा दिख
रहा होगा यहां पे ये ऐसे फज कर सकते हैं
यहां पे होस्ट के लिए ऐसे फज कर सकते हैं
फिर अ यू कैन फज लाइक
अदर तरीके से भी कर सकते हैं चलिए अब हम
यहां पे हान एफएफ यफ दे दिया हमने एंड
यहां पे अब हान यू न u दिया अब यहां पे हम
फर्च करते हैं एटीटीपी कॉलन स्ल स्ल अब
यहां पे सब डोमेन फाइंड करना है ना फज
करना है तो फज पहले ही कीवर्ड हमने लगा
दिया क्या लगा दिया भाई सब लोग देख रहे हो
ना फज फज डॉट अब किसका टेस्ला टेस्ला कॉ
तो हमने फज कर दिया
tesla.svs
न य से टारगेट यूआरएल है भैया
आपका हान ड वर्डलिस्ट ठीक है हान डब् यह
रहा वर्डलिस्ट फाइल पाथ ठीक है भाई तो
वर्डलिस्ट देते नड से हान डब् कहां पे है
स्ल रूट डेस्कटॉप
एंड यह वाली फाइल है ना कौन सी क्या नाम
था इसका नोको था ना नो नो नको सबन हमने दे
दिया ठीक है भैया तो हमने यह सारी चीजें
कर दी अब हम इसको एंटर करेंगे और लेट्स सी
व्ट इज
हैपनिंग देखो क्या कर रहा है
य यह सब डोमेंस को फाइंड कर रहा है गाइस
याद
रखिएगा दिस लिटरली फाइंडिंग द सब डोमेंस
मतलब जो सब डोमेंस जिस इनिशियल से है ना
जैसे statista.com
mobile.com shop.com
apps.com ये वो लिस्ट निकाल रहा है और
यहां पे स्टेटस कोड्स भी दे रहा है 301
403 403 अब इसमें से आपको अगर 200 वाले
सिफ चाहिए तो आप इसको भी फिल्टर आउट करने
का यहां पे इनपुट में दे सकते हो जैसे यह
देखो
अ ये देखो फिल्टर एटीटीपी स्टेटस कोड्स
फ्रॉम रिस्पांस h एसी ठीक है ना तो न एसी
से आप स्पेशली अगर आप चाहते हो सिर्फ और
सिर्फ एक पर्टिकुलर फिल्टर हो जाए तो वो
आप कर सकते हो और हान एमसी लगा दोगे तो
मैच करने जैसे सिर्फ दो 200 सॉरी सिर्फ
200 वाले आपको स्टेटस कोड्स वाले आपको
आउटपुट चाहिए तो हान एसी 200 लगा दोगे
सिर्फ 200 वाले ही आपको यहां पे ये खोज के
देगा तो ये इस तरीके से आप फज भी कर सकते
हो हान एमसी लगा दीजिए 200 लगा दीजिए और
अब आपको जो रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे जनरली ये
आपको क्या मिलेंगे भैया ये आपको मिलेंगे
200 वाले ओनली जो वर्किंग सब डोमेंस हैं
वही मिले गट
इट समझ में आ
गया समझ में आ गया सबको एवरीवन गेटिंग दिस
वन य 200 वाले इससे आप पर्टिकुलर क्या
निकाल सकते हैं सबड फाइंड कर सकते
हैं ठीक है एफफ यूफ यू कैन आल्सो
ट्राई
ठीक
है
ओके
चलिए सो दिस वे दिस आर द वेज यू कैन फाइंड
द सब डोमस तो हमने आज के सेशन में बेसिकली
क्याक करा यहां पे हमने यहां पर क्या की
क्या चीजें करी है यहां पे के के
सर्ट एस एस सब फाइंडर एफएफ यफ यूज किया
शॉटिंग की हमने सब लिस्टर का यूज नहीं
किया है आप यूज कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं एडीपी एकस एटीपी प्रोब किया लाइव सब
डोमेन के लिए ठीक है एंड केस एंड आई
विटनेस को यूज किया स्क्रीनशॉटिंग के लिए
हमने एंड हमने स्क्रीनशॉट भी लिया यूनिक
हमने तो हमने अब क्या किया हमने इसको अब
हम इसको एक थोड़ा सा समरा इज करके आपको
दिखा देता हूं हमने क्या
किया
सिलेक्टेड सिलेक्टेड अ
टारगेट सेकंड में फाउंड ऑल पॉसिबल सब
डोमेन यूजिंग
डिफरेंट मेथड्स
एंड
टूल्स रिमूव्ड द
डुप्लीकेट सब
डोमस ठीक है उसके बाद
फिल्टर्ड द लाइव सब डोमस
लाइव एंड फाइनल सब डोमेंस
फिथ
में टूक
स्क्रीनशॉट एंड एनाला
एनालाइज बस यह किया अब इसके बाद जो
स्टेप्स बचते हैं नेक्स्ट स्टेप्स क्या हो
सकते हैं
आपके एनालाइज द स्क्रीनशॉट्स
फॉर पॉसिबल
वलन बिलिटी उसके बाद डू अ
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्स
फॉर फॉर सेंसिटिव फाइल्स सेंसिटिव
फाइल्स जेस फाइल
एनालिसिस जेस जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल एनालिसिस
यह सारे स्टेप्स अभी अभी तो बहुत सारे
स्टेप्स है
वैसे गिट हब
रिकन ये सारे स्टेप्स अभी बहुत सारे
स्टेप्स बचे हुए हैं अभी ये सारे स्टेप्स
अभी है पॉसिबल अभी और भी बहुत सारी चीजें
हैं वो कर सकते हैं अभी हम और भी करेंगे
आगे चलके और भी चीजें हम और भी टारगेट पे
करने वाले हैं याद रखिएगा तो ये चीजें भी
हम सीखने वाले हैं फिलहाल आज के लिए हमने
बस इतना किया है ये स्टेप्स बाद के हैं
इसको मैं हटा देता हूं अभी फिलहाल हमें
अबी इसकी जरूरत नहीं है ठीक है यह सारे
काम हमने आज किया एचटीटीपी एक एचटीटी प्रो
कोई सा भी काम आप जो है आप कमांड जो यूज
कर सकते हो टूल यूज कर सकते हो दोनों यूज
कर सकते हो ठीक है एसडी कर लो एसडीपी कर
लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है ठीक है कोई सा भी टूल यूज कर लो एसडीपी
एसडीपी एक्स एसटीटी प्रोब एसटीटी पी हो
एटी पीएस हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है हां एपीआई की रिसेट करने की बात है
एपीआई की रिसेट करनी पड़ेगी रिसेट मैं अभी
कर लेता हूं इसकी जिसकी दिख गई थी
मुझे ओके इनवेलिड सीस आरफ टोकन क्यों ऐसा
क्यों भाई अकाउंट तो चल रहा है
ना चलो हो गया होगा शायद रिसेट ठीक है चलो
अच्छी बात है बाकी इधर तो रिसेट उधर उसका
तो कोई जरूरत है नहीं उसकी आप कर लोगे तो
कोई दिक्कत नहीं चलो थैंक यू सो
मच बताऊंगा मैं आपको बताऊंगा क्या होता है
अब आपका एक टास्क है सब लोगों का टास्क
क्या है भैया आप सब लोगों के एक टास्क है
पहला टास्क यह
है चूज
टारगेट एंड फाइंड ऑल पॉसिबल सब
डोमस ठीक है पहला उसके
बाद रिमूव डुप्लीकेट्स
फिल्टर लाइव सब
डोमस फिल्टर लाइव फाइनल सब लाइव सब डोमस
एंड मेक अ फाइनल
लिस्ट फाइनल लिस्ट यह काम करना है
दूसरा दूसरा यहां पे टेक स्क्रीनशॉट ऑफ ऑल
स्क्रीनशॉट ऑफ ऑल लाइव सब डोमेन
लाइव सब डोमेन स्क्रीनशॉट ले लेना भ आपको
तीसरा टैग
अस अपलोड योर वर्क ऑन गल ड्राइव एंड पोस्ट
ऑन लिंकडन विथ लिंक एंड
टैग एंड टैग डि फोनिक्स ऑन
लिंकन यह आपको टैगिंग करनी है डिक्स को
लिंकन प आपको कर देना भैया ठीक है आप चाहे
तो इसकी स्क्रीनशॉट लेकर आप और टेक
स्क्रीनशॉट ऑफ वर्क एंड टैग
ऑन इा इा पर क्या किसको टैग करना है ट टीम
डि फोनिक्स को टैग करना है ट टीम डि
फोनिक्स या ट टेक्निकल नेविगेटर इसको भी
आप कर सकते हैं यह काम आपको करना है यह
आपका एक टास्क है चौथा चौथा टास्क क्या है
देख लीजिए ट्राई हैक मी पे चले जाइएगा
ट्राई हैक मी पे और यह वाला प्री
सिक्योरिटी वाला आपको कंप्लीट कर लेना है
जिनका बच गया है कंप्लीट द प्री
सिक्योरिटी कंप्लीट प्री सिक्योरिटी
लर्निंग
पाथ पांचवा
कंप्लीट
कंप्लीट काली लिनिक्स
प्लेलिस्ट
फ्रॉम पार्ट
ट6 ऑन टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
youtube1 प्लीज डू दिस एंड आई होप कि आप
सब इस टास्क को करके लाएंगे तो गाइस यह आज
की सेशन थी यह हमारे सोशल मीडिया हैंडल्स
है यह हमारा एक साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
मास्टरी कोर्स है जिसको आप इनरोल कर सकते
हैं de.com साइबर सिक्योरिटी मास्टरी
कोर्स लिंक पे जाके या तो हमारा रस एडमी
का ए एप्लीकेशन इंस्टॉल कीजिए वहां जाइए
वहां भी ये कोर्स अवेलेबल है आपको फिलहाल
डिस्काउंट में मिल जाएगा एंड इनरोल कीजिए
एंड एथिकल हैकिंग की अपनी जर्नी को
स्टार्ट कीजिए ठीक है और ए एप्लीकेशन
डाउनलोड मत करना भूलिए एडिक्स एडमी नाम से
ठीक है ये सारी चीजें कीजिए मस्ती में
रहिए एंड अच्छे से जाइए डिनर कीजिए मस्ती
कीजिए खाइए पीजिए एंड सो जाइए और अपने काम
में लग जाइए एंड हंटिंग करते रहिए हैप्पी
हंटिंग एंड विश यू अ गुड लक फॉर व्हाट एवर
यू आर डूइंग एंड आप म मजे में कीजिए अच्छे
से कीजिए आई होप कि आज की सेशन आपको अच्छी
लगी होगी सेशन अच्छी लगी होगी रियली में
अच्छी लगी होगी तो दोस्तों को भी शेयर
करना मत भूलिए शेयर करते हैं तो आप केयर
करते हैं हमारी और हमारी केयर करते हैं
मतलब हम भी आपकी केयर करते हैं और आपको एक
क्वालिटी कंटेंट्स प्रोवाइड करते जाएंगे
जितनी ज्यादा सपोर्ट आप लोग अच्छा सपोर्ट
दिखा रहे हो भाई इतना तो मुझे पता है थैंक
यू सो मच इतने अभी अभी जो इतने सपोर्ट
दिखा रहे हो इतने के लिए लाइव में आया करो
ज्यादा मजा आएगा आपको लाइव अगर आप
रिकॉर्डिंग के भरोसे रहोगे ना फिर वो मजा
नहीं आएगा याद रखिएगा और रिकॉर्डिंग तो
पता नहीं कब क्या
youtube0 की क्लासेस हैं तो ये लीगल है
ऑथराइज्ड है कोई टेंशन नहीं है बट स्टिल
लाइव में आइए ज्यादा मजा आपको आएगा इतना
मैं बोलूंगा ठीक है एंड सभी लोगों को एक
बार फिर से थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द
सेशन एंड आई होप आपको अच्छा लगा होगा तो
अभी एक बार सब लोग लास्ट में बाय गुड नाइट
कर दो ताकि मैं भी सेशन को एंड कर दूं और
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में कल का दिन
ओबवियसली गैप रहेगा एक गैप तो रहेगा ही एक
दिन का और जब नेक्स्ट सेशन होगी उसके पहले
आप टास्क कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा ये टास्क के
स्क्रीनशॉट आप लोग ले सकते हैं अगर आप
चाहते हैं तो आगे फरदर रिटेन करने के लिए
ठीक है और अगर आप मुझे फॉलो करना चाहते
हैं
पेज पे आ जाइएगा linkedin.com
फरदर अपडेट्स वगैरह के लिए जो भी अपडेट्स
है आपको यहां पे मिलती जाएंगी भैया और इस
पे आपको कंटेंट्स मिलेंगे अलग-अलग साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के डिफरेंट डिफरेंट काइंस ऑफ
इंटरेस्टिंग कंटेंट्स ठीक है चलिए ओके दो
दिन की क्लास छूट गई है कल का गैप है
कंप्लीट मारो कल का पूरा गैप रहेगा उस दो
दिन की क्लास को कंप्लीट मारो सारी
वीडियोस देखो मैं आपको बार-बार बोल रहा
हूं भाई बिना उसके आप आगे नहीं बढ़ो ग
एक-एक आपको एक-एक वीडियो देख के फिनिश
करनी है जैसे आप आओगे यहां पे चैनल पे आप
आओगे डिफन अकेडमी पे प्लेलिस्ट में आ जाना
सॉरी लाइव में आ जाना लाइव में आओगे यहां
पे बग बाउंट की डे वन वाली वीडियो से लेकर
और आपको आज तक की वीडियो देखनी है सब
जिनका जो छूटा है देखते चले जाइए डे वन
देख लीजिए फिर डे टू देख लीजिए फिर डे
थ्री देख लीजिए डे फोर डे फाइव डे सिक्स
डे सेवन डे एट से पहले तक कंप्लीट कर
लीजिए यही मेरी आपसे एक बहुत बड़ी
रिक्वेस्ट है भैया ठीक है चलिए थैंक यू सो
मच गाइस थैंक यू कुलदीप थैंक
यू एंड
ठीक है टे ग्रा प कीजिएगा मैं आपको
बताऊंगा कुछ अल्टरनेटिव उसका चीपर
अल्टरनेटिव कुछ समझाऊ बता दूंगा आपको मेरी
टीम से कोई भी आपको मैसेज कर देगा ठीक है
तो टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है ऑफिशियल अंडर
टीएन यह एक हैंडल है अंडर ऑफिशियल अंडर
टीएन ठीक है
चलिए टाटा बाय बाय गाइस एंड सबको गुड नाइट
थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग नेक्स्ट सेशन
में भी ऐसे ही जवाइन कीजिएगा ऐसे ही
प्रेजेंस बना के रखिए और मस्त मस्त कंटेंट
आपको लाकर दूंगा मैं ठीक है शेयरिंग जरूर
कर ना भाई शेयर कर दोगे ना मजा आ जाएगा
whatsapp-web